están en modo de solo escucha bienvenidos ahora que creo es la 16 sábado 16 gracias alberto
gracias el castellano perfecto clase diecimo sexta clase a ver que he dejado el one drive abierto
y bueno espérate que lo voy a dejar porque más que nada es más un poco más eficiente hacerlo
desbloqueo un momento no así no es pero casi queda más más limpio todo bien vamos allá vamos allá
que tenemos bastantes cositas tenemos bastantes cositas empezamos siempre por el disco logremos
a por folio recuerdo que esta va a ser la última clase al uso bueno es la última clase pero queda
una que esta clase será en un mes y por lo tanto será de dudas pero si algo quedará pendiente
lógicamente de ésta pues también también se podría aprovechar en las dudas para comentar
vale y ya he ido subiendo hoy algunas cosas de manera avanzada que ahora voy a subir más voy a
subir más pero ya subido algunas que no eran digamos típicamente de la clase de hoy relacionadas
pues subí el buscador de entradas salidas que lo teníamos pendiente con 23 entradas y no sé si
dan 35 salidas que recuerda sólo un no deja de ser un ejemplo por ejemplo yo que sé indicador
sólo hay el rsi pero podéis poner otros de figuras de velas pues está el martillo pero
podéis poner otras entonces al final no deja de ser una plantilla donde podéis hacer ahí 70
pero para que veáis un poco en la manera y el esquema no el esquema de que podéis
poder trabajarlo y podéis esglosarlo buscar solo de indicadores o lo de tal vale decir un poquito
para trabajar y buscar y buscar ideas cuando uno no tiene que a veces no hace falta es no hace
falta y puedes sentarte en algunas vale luego por cierto no he preguntado si se oye y lo que
no lo he escrito se me oye todo el mundo me oye todo el mundo me oye los que me oís ya lo sé mario
no me oye no me oye por eso ha contestado que no ha contestado que no venga bien luego luego
también he subido aquí un pack de forex para responder a una pregunta que había ahora en
pregunta que lo vemos allí y he subido dos artículos bastante interesantes sobre filtros
principalmente para las estrategias breakout como de esto hemos hablado bastante os pasamos y
hablamos de las bastantes figuras de filtro y quería ya esta imagen ponerla hace tiempo que
es un poco una imagen típica de cómo se filtra por volatilidad entradas vale todo siempre es
discutible todo hay que probarlo y al final el vector más más más importante de todos luego
subiré un pdf de caos mar que me gusta muchísimo que ya lo tengo preparado hace tiempo lo quería
subir el último día a esto es porque aquí antes estaba buscando si había subido ya está
que justamente hablaba de eso le acuerdo el vector principal para que un sistema funciona
es el tipo de mercado entonces si te empeñas en un activo muy tendencial meterle mi reversión
pues va a ser complicado y viceversa de ser un activo típicamente mi reversión te empeñas en
en tendencia pues complicado vale entonces el vector principal siempre es siempre es el tipo
las características del activo vale y por eso también por ejemplo este este buscador de entradas
salidas se puede usar un poco para eso para ver qué tipo qué tipo de entradas van mejor coger
2 3 típicas tendenciales 2 3 típica mi reversión y ver esa es una pequeña optimización rápida a
ver qué cómo se respira el activo en ellas pues es una manera también de ver qué tipo cómo cómo
cómo va a decir las de breakout va muy bien para ver si el activo tiene tendencia es decir si tú
compras o vendes al máximo de ayer y cierras al final de días es una manera ya lo comenté creo
que en la teoría y la práctica bueno simplemente compras es compran stop en el máximo de ayer y
venta en corto en el mínimo de ayer y cierre a fin de día de acuerdo eso una normalmente es un
buen indicador de la tendencialidad de un activo tendes pero ya digo muchas de las entradas que
hay os pueden servir para eso pueden servir para eso de manera sencilla de manera sencilla sin
complicarnos y buscar coeficientes de cursos y cosas más complejas vale que al final se van a
llevar al mismo sitio entonces eso es es útil para ver las capacidades de un activo bien entonces
lo que digo aquí en la los filtros viene así entonces es verdad que tú dices hombre sobre todo
para la expansión o tendencialidad a veces cuando empieza la tendencia puede haber una expansión y
seguir la expansión es verdad o sea no quiere decir ningún filtro actúa bien el 100% de las
veces entonces al final si tú digamos que lo que aumentas es tu probabilidad de éxito reúces
muchos straights reúces buenos y reúces malos lo que tienes que hacer es reducir más malos pero
evidentemente no hay filtro perfecto no te va a clavar siempre la situación y de hecho hay
veces que como yo os he dicho yo muchas veces que veo artículos de donde se filtra que yo no
filtraría prefiero que el sistema rinda peor y opere más que filtrarlo en exceso pero no deja
de ser añadir la complejidad y a darle dificultar las robustez entonces hay que tiene que hacer
falta y tiene que haber una mejora significativa y seguir mantiendo un número de trades porque
sino a lo mejor no vale la pena filtrarlo vale la pena diversificarlo con otros sistemas como
ahora vamos a ver maneras donde un sistema que no es tampoco especialmente bueno y aporta recuerdo
decir al final esto esto pasa vale bien en cuanto a preguntas muy rápido
aquí se me ha añadido más ha habido más ha habido más que siempre apura esa última
hora me preguntas albert ya durante horario de clase durante horario de clase me suelta
es otra pregunta bien no no que está bien sabe saber pero entonces no me dejáis leer la mera
voy abajo arriba porque ya llegaré a todas tranquilos vale podemos descargar recibir los
vídeos antes de tener que nos ordenador no no no es posible alber lo siento mucho pero no es posible
normalmente no es así casi ninguna formación por un tema de seguridad de copyright de acuerdo es
decir no pero aprovecho porque había alguna pregunta por email y ha pensado que la contestaría en
directo recuerdo que el mínimo tiempo que vais a tener acceso es después de acabar es decir pos la
casa clase que ahora espérate que el 15 alberto a ver un momentito 11 o 11 de junio vale a partir
del 11 de junio mínimo un año más mínimo un año más y tampoco también quiero decirles que no
vamos a ir y que depende lógicamente de si hay situaciones y hay historias parece tampoco vamos
a hacer si hay un motivo para alargarlo pues se habla y se cometa pero en principio mínimo un
año más yo creo que es mucho tiempo de paciente que va a estar casi casi bueno más año y medio
disponible un año incluso pero mínimo mínimo es es un año que creo que es tiempo más que
suficiente más que suficiente entonces al ver más con los meses va a ser un año vale un año más
a partir de un año a partir de el próximo 11 de junio desde hoy un año y un mes mínimo
vale luego manuel voy de abajo arriba como he dicho porque así pues es más fácil como él comentaba
que decía la matriz de excel para elegir sistemas relacionados y tener un porfavor lo más alto
posible se verá lo que queda de clases ya que entiendo que es algo muy relevante la toma de
decisiones pero esto ya se vio en la teoría como no tengo que decir no sé exactamente a qué a qué
te refieres no sé a qué te refieres porque esto nosotros lo hacemos cada vez es decir al final un
excel no sé si es que en alguna clase te dije que te lo daré no no recuerdo la verdad no recuerdo
pero enseñarlo ya lo hemos enseñado ya lo hemos enseñado y bueno o sea no es un excel que tengamos
especial para hacerlo cada vez sale uno tienes o sea se construye tiene más más historia con la con
unas con unas correlaciones y demás que entiendo que te refieres a eso si no te refieres a eso
acláramelo si no enviarnos un email y tratamos de tratamos de mirarlo de mirarlo para estas cosas
también pues quedará esa clase un poco de seguridad no de seguridad para ver pasar el tema de los
codes y que es verdad que lo o sea ya lo he oído diciendo Juan Manuel de verdad que estoy casi
seguro seguro que va a haber alguna cosa que dije que haría que no voy a hacer es decir porque es
que como como comentamos en algún momento que para decir es creo que vamos a parar bien creo
que vamos a parar en un nivel muy bueno y que todo el mundo creo que que tiene motivos para
lógicamente lo diréis vosotros pero esa es mi opinión esa es mi opinión esa es mi opinión
se podría hacer más siempre se puede hacer más o sea es que siempre se puede hacer más y podríamos
hacer clases 20 más es que no habría problema en hacer más clases por por temario de acuerdo
porque podríamos seguir tocando más cosas para utilizar más aún se puede siempre hacer más es
que no no se acaba nunca pero es que tampoco se va a acabar o sea tú después del curso tampoco
vas a acabar al final lo que lo que el curso pretende es daros bases por las bases y herramientas
de acuerdo y herramientas y por eso tratamos incluso hemos ido añadiendo material hoy va a
haber más artículos prefiero decirlo la obra que ya lo sabéis de revistas incluso de pago hemos dado
un montón de material hemos dado todo el material de starts hemos dado todo el material de traen
de strategy concepts también de pago aunque ya ha descatalogado y hemos dado alguno que al principio
empecemos poniéndolos en vuelo nuestros ya ahora ya al final he dicho los subo directos ahora os voy
a poner varios de hecho algunos ya los he puesto esto que hay aquí esto que hay aquí material
filtros breakout vale estos que hay dos artículos
revista de pago de pago para que nosotros estamos suscitos bueno esto es un
poco pues ahí sólo exclusivo para alumnos como material pero ya está y estamos dando todo el
material que podemos y todavía daremos todavía daremos más para daros herramientas pero es un
poco de lo que de lo que de lo que se trata no de hacer hacer hacer podrías no acabar nunca
podemos no acabar nunca haciendo y como ya he comentado en algún momento tenemos que parar
porque es que es así es a nuestro nuestro día a día es obvio creo que ya lo he dicho muchas veces
está afectado nosotros no no mientras siga el curso nuestro rendimiento nuestra productividad es
menor y nosotros nos dedicamos a eso no no no es no es como alguien que se dedica a la formación
que hay mucha gente y como ya también he comentado en algunos momentos la formación pues bueno tiene
cosas buenas y malas las buenas es que al final pues sabéis que nosotros pues hablamos de gente
que se dedica a esto de verdad y y la mala pues es que claro que el tiempo pues pues es limitado
y tenemos que ir preparando las cosas sobre la marcha entonces yo creo que ya al nivel de horas
que vamos a hacer va a ser muy muy importante pero insisto que cualquier cosa que digáis
que digáis trataremos de cubrirla y que creo que vaya a aportar de cubrirla en la última clase
entonces lo ve los coches que lo comentaré porque es un tema sencillo no es muy muy muy
complicado a nivel de rotacional como tal como tal no hemos dado ninguno es verdad no no tenía
pensado incluir nada específicamente rotacional es un tema muy muy concreto es un tema muy muy
concreto y que podemos dar cuatro pautas pero es que es que ya digo es un tema muy específico es
un tipo de sistemas muy específico como los temas estacionales y al final no deja de ser aplicar
un poco lo mismo pero de otra manera todo se basa un poco en lo mismo no lo de montar un
vídeo como servidor sí que lo habíamos desechado con manuel pero simplemente simplemente por un
tema por un tema de coste beneficio es decir realmente dedicar horas del curso a eso aporta
más que dedicarlas a otra cosa la verdad que hemos tenido dudas porque encontrarás manuales
de eso y no sé no sé la verdad sabes no no no tenemos la sensación que sea algo que aporte
mucho no ya sé que aporta se me entiendo se aporta aporta todo pero pero al final hay que
elegir en qué gastar el tiempo entonces no tengo claso que sea algo que aporta mucho porque no
tiene tampoco una especie de complejidad y puedes encontrar material de todas maneras ya digo enviar
vuestras peticiones y tratamos de descuadrarlo yo que sé igual con el tiempo pues podemos montar
un taller extra no sé sabes lo que te quiero decir de cosas concretas que haya demanda y montar
un taller no sé podemos valorar otras otras opciones tema de bix sí que es verdad que lo
comenté lo del bix recuerdo y sí que había algún tenemos algún sistema por ahí de bix como como
filtro es un tema bastante avanzado la verdad es un tema bastante bastante avanzado y también
lo habíamos decidido no darla por por por por complejidad y por lo que por lo mismo que te digo
ahora por tiempo de acuerdo vamos a ver cómo va la última clase a nivel de preguntas me lo
estoy apuntando apuntando y si si diera tiempo si miramos que no hay una demanda brutal de dudas
y demás pues podríamos tratar de hacer cuatro tips 4 tips de porque brevemente te lo puedo
explicar en 15 20 minutos vale pero ya está vale profundizar mucho más no podremos pero pero ya la
idea la idea que es lo importante la en todo esto no el hecho pues te la sigue te la podría dar la
idea así que podría así que me lo apunto y trataré tiene que ser la idea brevemente de acuerdos
dejarla en la en esta última en esta última clase vale se podrá preguntar si si se puede
preguntar se puede preguntar de acuerdo se puede preguntar al disco los alumnos vais a seguir en
el disco de acuerdo este todo este periodo que digo mínimo va a seguir para irse a seguir en
el disco en el disco de alumnos en el disco en general puede ser cualquiera pero el disco
de alumnos este periodo podéis estar y por lo tanto se puede preguntar nosotros trataremos de
ir respondiendo en el disco de acuerdo no en ese caso ya así que será en el disco parece que
será en el disco y no será de manera mejor pues tan rápida de semana a semana intentaremos
hacerlo hoy intentaremos hacerlo y intentaremos ir respondiendo al final el soporte va a seguir
el soporte el soporte va a seguir pero claro centrado en el curso es decir al final lo que
tampoco tiene este creo que es obvio no es centrado en lo que hemos dado en dudas y demás cosas que
salgan de ahí un poco pues bueno ya digo es por ejemplo son el mismo pero pues podemos tratar de
poner cosas más bien concretas más bien concretas podemos abordarlo pero la respuesta es sí soporte
el soporte por discord correo continúa y continúa eso no no acaba se incluye en este periodo que
os digo vale lo he respondido cualquier cosa me la vais incluyendo sea aquí o sea en el chat o
el disco Raúl Raúl comentaba que se había pasado de una estrategia mira esto de la estrategia limit
al final a ver a ver que puedo abrir y ahora rápido porque no tenía abierto
tres sesión para darle rendimiento a pero podemos abrir algún algún bus pays por aquí
los rápidos a ver clases para abro el buscador un momento y hasta abro el buscador un momento
por el buscador un momento y listos las dos curvas que enseñas Raúl están interesantes el final
el limitado no no toque aclarar un par de cosas también luego en rik que es comprensible siempre
quedan quedan dudas que se comentó que no era buena idea hacer batesco no es que sea buena idea a
lo mejor algunas veces claro cuando no habla tantas horas por algunas cosas se equivoca es en el
matiz o no no es que haya dicho cosas incorrectas pero sí que a veces tengo la sensación que al
mejor en un matiz pues me he podido equivocar al final cuando tú haces bactés el límite por el
tema del de lo que expliqué del bactés que eso está en la teoría de por ejemplo el por qué usar
el look inside part testing y acordaros lo repaso muy brevemente muy brevemente porque al final el
motivo es un poco el mismo acuerdo a con perdón poder si estoy estoy yo con el gráfico arriba es
que de verdad es que es que de verdad venga al final de cualquier vela vale de cualquier vela
tú ahora aquí tienes esta vela que es en tiempo real vale si eso está cargando datos que no lo
sé cargando datos se ha movido el precio aumento sí sí sí sí está tiempo real vale esta vela
en tiempo real si yo tuviera aquí órdenes pues ejecutaría por motivos obvios de cualquier vela
anterior a la de tiempo real es igual si es en un minuto o en diario de acuerdo la vela de tiempo
real la vela derecha del todo de acuerdo esa es la vela de tiempo real vale y esa por lo tanto
tiene sus propias reglas para ejecutar órdenes que es bastante obvio la que toca antes no porque
este tiempo real ahí no hay problema el problema es para las históricas de acuerdo la anterior a
esa es decir ya la anterior vale esta vela de aquí de acuerdo ya es una vela histórica vale y
por lo tanto a ver que voy a oscurecer porque siempre pasa lo mismo venga esta vela ya se calcula
por historia y de esa vela en principio tenemos el hike el low el open y el close sólo esos cuatro
datos de acuerdo y las reglas por la que va a ejecutar el sistema si la orden se ejecuta si
hay dos y hay stops y hay tp de orden para entrar o no pues lógicamente depende del
recorrido de la vela muchas veces como en esta el recorrido parece obvio aún así a veces el obvio
no es obvio pero fíjate la anterior que ya no es tan obvio de acuerdo esta que fue primero para
arriba luego para abajo y volvió o primero para abajo luego para arriba claro si tú vinieras
comprado o si tú tuvieras que abrir imagínate primero el largo primero va para arriba te pone
largo luego para abajo a lo mejor te salta el stop en cambio si va primero para abajo y luego
va para arriba y se queda largo perfecto porque al día siguiente ha subido cambia completamente
la película entonces sólo sabe por reglas de backtest vale bien pues las órdenes límite aún
va a un paso más de eso vale va un paso más de eso porque porque yo al final cuando pero es esto
el mercado es esto el mercado es esto que ves puerta y demanda y si yo me pongo un orden límite ahora
estoy aquí en simulado si ahora que me pongo un orden límite bueno aquí el simulado bueno aquí
no puedo en que letras estamos a ver todo ese m m estamos m no m m de bien perfecto vale entonces
ahora aquí si me pongo aquí yo me pongo ahí limitado el simulado me pongo ahí yo soy ahora
comprando un contrato ahí vale si el precio llega a ver si hay 130 órdenes 130 contratos bueno no
se lo veis 135 va cambiando esos tiempos real eso es en el simulado y no va a simular la cola
pero en tiempo real llegaría y yo me he puesto cuando había 130 que dice que a lo mejor soy
el 131 vale entonces si se ejecutan sólo 50 mis mi orden no se va a ejecutar porque yo estoy a
partir del 130 entiendes entonces este es el problema en las limitadas garantizar que se ha
ejecutado vale entonces cómo lo garantizas pues cuando toca el tic siguiente es decir si yo me he
puesto comprando a 5221 si toca 5220 con 75 es 100% seguro que se ha ejecutado el 21 mientras no se
ejecute no toque el tic siguiente yo puedo tener alguna duda de que se haya ejecutado entiendes
que ese es el problema del backtest estar seguro hay gente depende del sistema lo puedes ignorar
más depende del activo pues es más sensible que es lo que garantiza eso para cancelamos la orden
lo garantiza poner un backtest activar esta opción en backtesting fill inter orden o en
trade price exit exit limit price es decir sólo ejecutar sólo marcarla ejecutada cuando se
excede el precio esa es la manera más conservadora hay gente que no lo hace y marca esta es menos
conservadora porque habrá veces que ejecutar habrá veces que no y puede cambiar mucho
depende el tipo de sistemas es un tema un sistema mean reversion que no tiene colas largas no tiene
su su beneficio su mejor operación no difiere demasiado de la de la media al final ejecutar
uno no es determinante pero en un tendencial ejecutar o no es muy determinante porque
normalmente el 20 el 80% del beneficio viene solo del 20% de los trades entiendes entonces
puede cambiar mucho las cosas ejecutar un trato no entonces al final depende un poco de eso ese
es el criterio conservador yo te recomiendo usar este siempre que siempre es mejor que te lo de
por decir aquí para más detalles de las agil y te da detalles vale en todas las plataformas está
esto eso está en todas las plataformas vale no tiene más más historia vale entonces esto es el
tema si activas esto no hay ningún problema no es el límite activa esta opción multichance también
está y en todas las plataformas vale y de esa manera sabrás al 100% que tu precio se hubiera
ejecutado verás que cuando actives eso alguna orden que habías puesto el límite no la ejecutará
porque ahora va a ser la idea que has clavado el mínimo para ponerte largo el máximo a ponerte
corto y cuando pasa eso no sabemos seguro si has ejecutado porque si habían 100 contratos en
ante tuyo cuando te pusiste tú sabes no lo sabes vale que no que queda que queda esto claro vale
esto sin guardar siguiente respondido clipito no lo he puesto así a no que lo ponemos
perdón vale enrique bueno te estás refiriendo a fixe ratio es el intuitivo nuevamente
ya me expliqué mal pero no es que no creo haber dicho que no la usaréis no creo haber dicho que
no la usaréis pero sí que dije que es más intuitiva la otra al final tienes que analizarlo
y estudiarlo de acuerdo aquí no sé si adquiriste msa o no está bastante bien explicado y también
tienes hasta la fórmula tienes la fórmula de fixe ratio vale que es lo que tú buscabas
vale que es lo que tú buscabas vale en fixe el ratio al final es la delta es verdad que
programáticamente es poco más compleja pero realmente es muy intuitiva a nivel de de operar
es decir si tienes la delta cuando yo digo que es poco intuitiva es decir porque no no no no va
relacionado como al riesgo es como decir bueno que delta uso es verdad que se recomienda la mitad
si podéis usarla es cuestión de estudiarla a mí me gusta ya expliqué la clase pasada cual
usamos para decir no voy a darle más más vueltas pero aquí tienes la fórmula es esta no tiene no
tiene más acuerdo no tiene más donde n 0 donde n 0 es la equity vale y hasta luego tienes otra
que viene relacionada porque aquí están todas generalizadas es decir adaptadas adaptas por
ejemplo generalizada quiere decir que la puedes que es que es fixe ratio porque la puedes adaptar
a distintos puedes regular el exponente y puedes regular con cuántos contratos empiezas vale
simplemente pero la fórmula es tan sencilla y tan difícil como ésta si la usas en su forma
generalizada aquí tienes también en la m que si usas 0 5 es el coeficiente de fixe ratio más
visto vale es el coeficiente fixe ratio vale y luego tienes la la p que es el beneficio de
los tres cerrados solo tienes que poner la equity la p no tienes que poner perdón acuiti las otras
que ponen el profe la equity no disculpame que fixe ratio justamente no depende de la
aquí la fórmula así que se pone el start y position size y tal pero pero no no es como fixe
risk que por eso digo que es más intuitiva en ese sentido pero sin más o sea poder por poder
podéis usarla acuerdo no tiene mayor entonces tú aquí en la fórmula habías puesto a ver me preguntaba
si era si era correcta y eso pues no lo he acabado de mirar porque ya pensaba mirarlo directamente
en directo vale
bueno no es ex a bueno partido por 2 que lo mismo que por 0 5 pues sí que estaría bien entiendo no
dos por n 0 si que es que solo lo que más hay que poner en 0 un poco para para usar la generalizada
que es lo que te digo no que al final no puedes haber que se me ha ido esto aquí
bueno está está yo puesto a esto te superaría la generalizada vale lo voy a pegar ahí vale
te lo voy a pregar y voy a pegar el inglés pero no voy a usar los traductores la explicación
debe ser que como digo está muy bien y por lo tanto pues es poco sentido que yo ahora pegue
algo más vale ahí lo tienes en el disco vale esa es la forma generalizada con el con el m 0 5 es
fixado rato directamente de acuerdo es decir es la única la única diferencia que puedes aplicar
vale tú lo has puesto dividido en vez de multiplicado está perfecto vale pero en programa en programación
ya os lo comenté es un poco mejor multiplicar que dividir pues cuando puedes evitar dividir
lo evitas cuando no pues no pasa nada no pasa nada simplemente es un poco más eficiente
simplemente es un poco más eficiente por tanto se hacía si alberto me comentaba algo antes así
si lo grafico superior si si me he dado cuenta me he contado me he contado no no pero ya lo he puesto
no lo pongo le he bajado si si eso ya está eso ya está si si que no me he dado cuenta no me he dado
cuenta ya lo ya lo he ya lo he bajado vale entonces ahí ahí está lo de lo del rick vale ahí está lo
de lo del rick entonces hay que probar hay que probar uno otro ahora ahora os enseñaré en
multicharts como que sigue estando pero que no no yo no te entiendo fran a ver cuéntame como
gráfico está en la parte superior pero si no hay ningún gráfico yo no estoy hablando de ningún
gráfico ahora está hablando de esto de no no estoy hablando de un gráfico no sé no sé qué te
ahora me lo sigo entonces aquí ya está también tal entonces lo del forest que ahora ligo con la
con la pregunta que bueno espera sigo sigo sigo con con decía raúl si lo divido por cero bueno
estoy ya te lo respondió ya te lo respondió al alberto es un tema sí es un tema de seguridad
igual que siempre que hay divisiones por cero es buena práctica que lo habéis visto en varios
códigos de trabas salidas también o sea se ve que hay posibilidad de ir por cero se consulta antes
porque dividir por cero es un error frecuente programación no se puede dividir por cero y
siempre que hay el riesgo de dividir por cero pues se hace un if antes no que si es mayor que cero
tanto si es igual que cero pues se le da cero cero uno se le da un valor tienes para evitar
división por cero pues esto siempre se hace se hace así que es lo que lo que pasa ahí de acuerdo te
dice si valor absoluto tal tal tal tanto si no vale 0 para evitar para evitar que si vale cero pues
no valga cero de acuerdo para evitar división por cero sin más eso es una es una es un criterio
de programación que siempre hay que tratar de evitar la división por cero y por eso se hace
sí sí sí sí sí entonces luego decía también en las preguntas de la buena una relacionada con
algún método para trabajar la estrategia de tres son darme que responde que no había vale bueno
eso también lo podía haber también lo podía haber respondido alberto pero bueno pues ha decidido
ha decidido no contestarla y la contestó yo sin ningún problema y bueno no es propiamente
esto objeto del curso no es propiamente no es que haya un método es decir al final simplemente
que si tú quieres ir en algo de cero pues hoy en día si tienes que empezar de cero párgame el
juego de palabras quizás sería mejor ya empezar en mql5 si tienes que empezar de acuerdo
pero pero no hay no hay un no hay un buen método de conexión vía tres son porque no
puedes o sea no no hay una traducción directa de easy language a mql5 no existe de acuerdo
simplemente tienes que si tú quieres usar 3d sobre que eres va a testear que también puedes
usar meta de 5 con algún adono lo que sea o puedes usar cualquier otra como siempre hemos dicho al
final no te queda más que traducir el código cuando al final puedas operar vía multichars que
es un principio es posible probable que pase dentro del ecosistema de algún ex me refiero
entonces sí que ya será más sencillo entonces ya no tengas problema porque lo harás con multichars
lo podrás hacer con multichars pero no hay un conector directo de acuerdo vía sí que es verdad
que vía meta de 5 puede ser vía python o sea tu meta de 5 sí que le puedes conectar otras cosas
puedes ir con python y no sé si con alguna más y puedes conectarla creo que también
interactivo que es no meta trader alberto 5 sí pero lo que no vas a poder es llevar ese lenguaje
al final el broker te tiene que pasar prometedor 5 tienes que acabar meta de 5 y ahí pues ya tienes
que verlo con el broker y mucha gente acaba yendo vía python por ejemplo vale o simplemente
traduciendo el lenguaje mql 5 traduciendo el sistema mql 5 ahí ya pues puedes usar herramientas
bueno hay mucha gente que está usando gpt para esas cosas ahora hay que vigilar decir hay que
tener conocimiento por los de gpt ayuda pues una ayuda para preguntarle cosas pero tampoco pensemos
que te lo va a dar todo porque si no te traduce me estoy sin lenguaje tal seguramente te va a
responder porque te responde todo fenómeno si no lo sabes se lo inventa y se queda más ancho que
espada si no lo sabes se lo inventa tienes y hasta y es así mientras cosas pero fácilmente
entonces pues hay que tener nociones pero así que tú le se lo pones y te lo va a traducir te lo va a
traducir entonces es así no lo pones y no va pero bueno pero pero el tiempo es podido pero pero si
lo sabes dirigir lo sabes tienes lo puedes ir dirigiendo tienes no puedes ir cosas concretas
poco a poco seguramente puedes llegar a una respuesta más o menos satisfatoria pero como
digo hay que tener conocimiento de acuerdo no no sin tener ni idea yo no lo aconsejo
vale entonces raúl ya ya estaría también al ver también al verte hacía había hecho había
hecho peticiones aquí en relación a mercado de divisas bien esto por un lado había puesto lo que
se va a tener que por cierto no lo he dicho aprovecha ahora para comentarlo bueno leo antes
el leo dice que hemos visto futuros acciones y tal pero que no hemos visto estrategias de fores que
sería interesante queremos algunas pautas así como las ventajas y convenientes diferencias de
comportamiento de divisas con respecto a los futuros y las acciones bueno tengo un artículo
por ahí que no he encontrado para esta vez me lo voy a apuntar también de referencia para la clase
esto lo daré he dado muchas he dado muchas pero pero lo haremos de pasado referencias
características es chulo para acabar también no el tipo de activos es verdad que el forex en sí
es como muy variable siempre pensar que al final a medida que va subiendo el transferente un día
comenté esto y creo que alguien me lo dijo normalmente la tendencialidad gana se entiende
es decir hay más tendencia en diario que entraría y más en semanal o en mensual no y eso también
pasa en el forex de acuerdo pero es verdad que el forex un mercado bastante de rangos pero ya
digo prefiero acabártelo de concretar de todas maneras al final albert no hay una o sea como
decía antes y que hay características de tipos de activo que van más en un tipo de activo u otro
pero al final la mejor manera y lo que tenéis que ir viendo y probando es aprender a hacerlos vosotros
que es lo que siempre desde el primer día incluso en el marketing que hemos dicho en el curso nosotros
pretendemos que se estebes logarítmicos no que salgáis con sistemas hechos o no dije seguramente
saldréis con ideas buenas pero no es el objetivo de acuerdo lo dije hasta las entrevistas con
victor tienes no no el objetivo no es darte 10 sistemas el objetivo es darte herramientas para
que tú sepas moverte vale y espero estar consiguiendo pero lógicamente tienes que seguir
a partir de ahí por ejemplo el código este tras salidas es una herramienta bastante potente para
esto que duda cabe que todo el manual que dimos de de ya lo diré de strategy concepts que además
os di un excel donde hice un análisis de cómo habían ido todos fuera de muestra vale todos fuera
de muestra que lo hice yo alguno uno pues también su material muy útil porque hay muchas ideas muy
potentes y todas vienen con sugerencias es decir que venían un poco también pensadas como ideas
para hablar no como para que cojas el sistema de lópez de acuerdo siempre están así esas ideas y
muchas muchas eran aprovechadas porque hasta había algunas interdiarias que estaban dando
profit factos fuera de muestra de 0 90 y pico que eso fuera de muestra teniendo en cuenta que es
solo la idea es muy probable que sea aprovechable es decir ahí hay un montón de ideas un montón de
materiales hay que hay que trabajándolo porque trabajando y además una gran manera de aprender
esto esto he dicho esto al final en el último día lo comentaremos pero ya digo es verdad que
sobre todo si vamos más a intradariario pues cuesta más tener tendencia los rangos de las
divisas son más estrechos los rangos de las divisas son más estrechos también eso permite
menos riesgo permite abalancar más y todo tiene su parte buena y su parte y su parte mala pero
al final no es tan distinto vale no es tan distinto al final es uno activo hay oferta y
demanda y lo que sí que tienes que lo mismo que los fds pues que ahí tienes vidias de acuerdo y
ahí es donde se plantea un poco el problema que es verdad que multichars permite gestionar eso
permite gestionar eso es eso no pero multichar si lo permite por un multichar si permite en una
pestaña que puedes elegir pactés clásico pactés avanzado y le puedes decir el bit y el ask y entonces
puedes hacer un pactés más realista en forex que trae estación por ejemplo vale pero dicho esto
dicho esto se ha añadido este material vale ese material es un material muy antiguo vale el forex
el forex pack a mí en algunos soneros me ha dado problemas de memoria si os da al final borrar la
tabla es que porque tiene un montón de datos que se calculan que algunos pues son para hacer
bonito como el que dice y hasta quedaros un poco con el con el con el gráfico de arriba y de la
derecha que lo voy a tratar de abrir lo voy a tratar de abrir el que ya tengo yo por aquí a ver
ahora ahora lo pongo lo pongo abajo porque es bastante interesante además ahí veis una pauta
realmente curiosa que para eso lo publicaron bueno curiosa interesante que es lo que hemos hablado
lo que enseñaba antes la volatilidad y viendo ese gráfico pues esto me suena no me suena a mí
haber visto a ver a ver me suena a mí algo me suena aquí una pauta de volatilidad claro aquí no y
por pues se puede eso aprovechar se puede mejor aprovechar a ver de forex para bueno tengo por
aquí el forex para que a ver si se abre este o me revienta puede ser que me reviente por eso
si esto lo abríis es algo parecido a esto y revienta que ya me está reventando creo
va a reventar por esto de aquí entonces ya nos revienta entonces esto si nos revienta
pues lo dejáis pero porque eso carga un montón hace un montón de solicitudes esto que creo que
ya lo puse ahí le tienes que poner el change porque si no nos lo va a calcular bien vale le
ponéis el change ahora ya está viendo donde pone usa donde pone tal y eso está moviendo que
el forex y el libro que está ahí dentro tiene parte interesante explica esto al final mercado
de 24 horas es referencia londres referencia new york tal y etcétera otros cada cada esto
tiene su referencia entonces el te pinta te pinta el color me parece que ya se ha bugueado y
y hasta te pinta en color las diferentes patas de volatilidad ya veréis que la volatilidad pues
casi cada día un comportamiento muy cíclico hay unas horas donde es alta donde es baja ergo a lo
mejor yo puedo en el forex mismo en esas pautas que veas el comportamiento tan típico con esta
sencilla imagen pues ya puedo ver qué tipo de estrategias en cada hora van mejor de acuerdo esto
es esto es esto es decir normalmente cuando ya hay expansiones para ser mejor a abrir
mientras esto cuidado porque es sólo para abrir ya digo parece contraintuitivo después una expansión
y revertir si porque el mercado recordados que los pasan un artículo de clave el que lo explicaba y
lo explicado yo la teoría expansión es contracción expansión contracción por lo tanto cuando hay una
expansión anticipa contracción ya está o sea hubiera sido cuando hay una expansión lo que
hubiera estado bien era estar estaría a favor de ella pero se ya ha pasado ya ya está tienes con
la actual contracción pasa lo mismo cuando por ejemplo decía antes este filtro que os decía que
usa el range no en ese documento que os he subido usa el range que busca contracción es para buscar
breakouts porque porque es eso después de que hay dos o tres días de contracción que el rango va
estrechándose es un buen momento para buscar expansiones o breakouts de acuerdo porque cuando
el mercado se congestiona la rotura suele ser buena se entiende no entonces es un poco lo que
hay detrás de estas estas ideas esto me parece que la televisión debe estar ya se ha roto pues
nada no pasa nada ahora la jaimitada será que me habré roto el me habré roto el porfolio no
igual alberto bueno bueno iniciaremos y está bueno si os pasa eso es un fallo es un eterno
problema de transición de que no se sienten cuatro bits y en estas estamos no en todos los
ordenadores pasa pero ahora mismo tengo transición colgadísimo y eso quiere decir que lo voy a
cerrar porque si no lo cierro pues mal vamos sería ya también a ver voy a cerrar todo también el
multichars y voy a cerrar ya lo tengo todo ahí está y espérate que lo tengo que cerrar a mano
porque estará totalmente totalmente bugueado por aquí está cerrado pero en cambio están todos
los procesos de transición abiertos como no puedo reiniciar pues no tengo que a veces es lo más
el ordenador ya está en este caso no me viene bien y por lo tanto pues tengo que ir cerrando
proceso por proceso vale parece que ya los he cerrado todos vale donde estaba bueno estamos
en el disco seguimos y luego ya voy abriendo abriendo porque si no vale esto ya estaba venga
seguimos al ver decía esto ya las otras cosas ya se las había respondido tú creo no que era
el tema de los paréntesis y demás sin comentar si entiendo que ya que ya está luego frank aquí
había hecho un par de mensajes ahí haciendo tres seguidos con casos de mori management y tal no a
ver en términos generales parto pienso por el principio por el principio en términos generales
o sea un caso de ahí algunos un poco extraños un poco esta es que lo decir de como rebuscados
vale y en todo en todo el tiempo hemos partido que la sencilla es es importante entonces este
esta idea tú cuando tengas dudas piensa siempre está por lo que piensa siempre es que si si lo
complicas demasiado probablemente no funcionará entonces al final cuando tú tienes a piramidar
al final lo que estás haciendo en el fondo cuando tú haces por folio piramidas tú tienes si tú
tienes varias estrategias imagínate en el sb ahora veremos por folio y habrán un par yo meto un sb
luego abre el otro sistema un sb en el fondo y piramidado porque abierto tres sb largo a favor
tenía uno y habrá otro pues tengo dos entonces que que es fácil en estos términos pues pensar
como una operación nueva entiendes pensar como una operación nueva entonces si tú tienes tu
mori management porque lo vas a cambiar porque lo vas a cambiar es decir al final el hecho de decir
y aplico el mismo aplico el doble pues no sé es que eso estará dimensionado correctamente estará
analizado y dependerá de eso dependerá de cómo tú dimensionas tu por folio que ya dimos
tips el otro día y vamos otra vez voy a dar si no daremos el último día también y por supuesto
que si me quedará algo daría otra clase nadie se piense que voy a decir algo por si no ha habido
tiempo no no lo que he dicho lo que he dicho estos dos tres días de que iba a dar eso sí que por
supuesto va a pasar grave por eso tranquilos pero entonces al final dices volvería a aplicar la
misma f mantiene las posiciones ampliando duplicando el riesgo así que eso ya estaría previsto antes
bueno si tú tienes una una yo que sé un 05 de moli management porque porque ya por el riesgo
que llevas y demás por por por el que ahora vamos a hablar de ello pues está está dimensionado así
lo mismo que por ejemplo si os acordáis cuando vimos el tps de conor pues ya está previsto que
hace cuatro entradas siempre así es decir está dimensionado tú lógicamente si haces un análisis
de eso pues tu cuenta tiene que estar dimensionada para que eso pase tu riesgo
medido para que eso pase entonces ya está estimado así que habrá veces que pondrá sólo dos y
podrás menos y claro por eso por ejemplo tps de conor al finales se expone muy poco y es difícil
exponerlo mucho porque claro que hay que dejar que puedas poner cuatro pero la mayoría de veces no
lo hace entiendes entonces sí es el problema también de piramidar yo casi te recomendaría
que de entrada no lo hagas vale que cada entrada no lo hagas es decir que porque
por temas de diversificación siempre es mejor tener la única motivo para hacerlo es decir yo
no tengo tengo que empezar a operar y no tengo más estrategias hoy puedes plantearlo así porque te
gusta como idea no es que sea mala pero siempre va a ser mejor añadir otro sistema para ese lote
que vas a piramidar otra estrategia distinta otra estrategia distinta siempre va a ser mejor pero
insisto al final lo tratas como una operación no me tiene que estar analizado antes por lo tanto
no metería efes distintas no no no complicaría no le daría tantas puertas de acuerdo usaría
mimo limanás en el que sea y punto de acuerdo en el que se ponen lo que sí que puede tener
distintas estrategias de salida distinta estrategias de uno tp otro no eso sí eso es
recomendable eso sí que puede tener tener sentido y sí que puede estar definido el sistema es decir
yo primero meto un 50% luego un 25 luego 25 eso puede estar definido así no quita la otra pero la
manera de medirlo de estimar el riesgo y demás tiene que estar preestablecido y adentrada en
ese supuesto decir que hago una vez no no cabe porque eso ya lo sabes antes de abrir
antes de abrir la primera ya sabes cómo abrirás la tercera y la cuarta y la segunda no cabe esa
duda y luego hablas también del tema de que añade perdedora sin ser una martingala por la
pero te entiendo de hecho te hablaba ahora de tps de conos que haces el mismo lo explica
lo dice cuidado eso solo vale para ETF para índices de acuerdo por ejemplo imagínate que haces eso
con google o con meta y te mete un 12% la baja de gap el día de resultados igual te hace un
30 entonces al final claro por eso ese tipo de cosas que tienen mucho riesgo solo en índices
porque porque un índice está más diversificado se ha protegido está prohibido que caiga más un
7 lo paran hay una serie de controles no y es más difícil más difícil vale
entonces tú planteas distintas opciones vale es que todas pueden valer o no pero hay que
aplicar si aplicaría es la misma y trataría los seis independientes es decir no eso bajaría
el tp de la primera al segundo intentando promediar ya digo piénsalo como operaciones
independientes cada trade que abres empieza tienes uno abierto y abres otro gestionado
gestionado de esa manera luego hablabas también de que de usar usar money management en evaluación
previa y demás si solo lo comentamos sobre todo sobre todo sobre todo donde esto es importante
sobre todo es en el acuerdo pero no está mal en distinto lo que único que hay que vigilar ahí
usar money management simplemente es para que para trabajar en porcentaje de acuerdo para trabajar en
porcentaje y adaptarnos un poquito al uso de la cuenta pero no siendo agresivo de ser siendo muy
moderado que si no nos hacemos un par de muchos años nos va a hacer la curva muy geométrica y es
poco también útil entonces tienes luego decías entiendo que vosotros utilizas fix a fractional
con tres riscos por volatilidad limitando un otaje máximo por baja volatilidad el otaje mínimo si
lo vimos en las primeras fases cual de estos sistemas de money management crees que son mejores
para aplicar bueno al final en general a nosotros nos gusta ese acuerdo os gusta es lo cual no
quiere decir que no que no cambiemos en el futuro porque este este money management lo estamos
usando hace unos pocos años antes habíamos usado fix el risk midiendo el riesgo como la
peor perdedora la media hemos hecho varias varias pruebas entiendes no hay no hay tampoco una
respuesta única hay mucha gente que aunque da peor el rendimiento le gusta mucho volatilidad la
volatilidad de avanzar se pone esperse en volatilidad que me sea lo tiene aunque te va a dar peores
ratios pero le gusta porque conceptualmente es parecido al nuestro ahora verías que el
nuestro en el fondo es una es un es un porque al final las matemáticas tienen eso no el
nuestro al final no deja de ser un que nosotros al provenir de la gestión colectiva o gestionados
a estas obligado a no pasarte del 100% pues proviene un poco de ahí tienes al final no deja
de ser un nominal máximo pero que se ajusta con ese límite ese límite que le ponemos de
cuando la volatilidad es baja al final actúa del límite de nominal entiendes porque yo
ahí al ponerle una variable fija y multiplicarlo como te enseñé si te fijas eso acaba siendo
nominal acaba siendo nominal por un multiplicador decir nominal puede ser el 100% 200 300 el que
sea te enseñaré uno creo que era 2.7 pero baja cuando la volatilidad sube todo es baja
entonces al final acaba siendo un nominal que reduce cuando la volatilidad sube es decir eso
es muy útil hacerlo es muy útil hacerlo todo es porque no usarlo entiendes pero fixe
te reyes fixe fracciones también está bien fixe el ratio al final lo importante es usar
anti martingales de acuerdo decir y y sentirte tú cómodo y explorarlo y trabajarlo vale pero
pero incluso ya digo nominal de acuerdo nominal no está mal tampoco problema de nominales que es
contra el tuitivo solo porque a medida que los precios caen te hace meter más en bolsa
no acaba no acaba siendo malo pero es el único pero que puede que puede tener vale damos a fran
también por el respondido y creo que ya estaría y voy a abordar tengo preguntas ahí en la clase
que no hayas respondido tú por favor si puedes responder tú ya lo respondes ya estamos al día
aquí había nada más por aquí a eso como momento es rica aquí preguntas esto es bueno se hace ya
días pero si realmente puedes poner un tico en el bar tenemos algo bueno es un principio lo responde
nosotros a veces no leído estos días pero a veces sí que lo que lo leo aquí aquí hay las
referencias bueno esto ya os vais digamos compartiendo cosas que está está muy bien
eso está muy bien esto está muy bien que lo que lo hagáis y ya me lo ya cuando tenga un
poco de tiempo lo que pasaré porque tengo muchos por la idea para el nivel del bar entonces ya
me lo miraré un poco con calma y si puedo aportar algo pues ya trataré también de aportarlos vale
venga acabo acabo esto esa parte con añadiendo material que quería añadir en directo para
hablarlo para hablarlo ya he subido lo que quería subir de tema anterior vale por eso subí el forex
pero apropiadamente de la clase por eso subí el buscador y por eso he subido el paque este de
filtros por el paque este de filtros que os he subido que puede ser para un rebe para un
breakout para para normalmente aunque realidad también se ven por el otro por esa misma imagen
porque es lo que el uno quiere es lo contrario del otro normal en cuanto a por folio quería
subiros dos papers que no subiros dos papers tres documentos tres documentos por un lado esto que
es un de un libro que no recuerdo que tengo hace muchos años impreso lo escaneado para daros lo
que era un gestor de commodities que sugería por folio es muy antiguo en realidad es muy
antiguo eso también en la relación en la relación que en las referencias características tipos de
activos y activos top me los estoy apuntando en la última clase os los diré hay algunos activos
en materias primas de activos que van muy bien y que va casi todo por ejemplo por ejemplo la
gasolina un futuro que le ponés un churro y saca y saca algo estoy exagerando pero me entendéis
son activos que por lo que sea pues pues bueno en tendencia en general en general en comodities
encontraréis muchos si vais explorando las commodities encontraréis muchas commodities que
van bien también que van bien en tendencia vale y por lo tanto ahí a nivel de futuros explorar lo
pasa que es verdad que en commodities ya la cosa se dispara de tema de grandes por eso aquí había
este porfolio que habrá si esto es una pasta pero con digamos una pequeña referencia sobre
en caso que yo pueda hacer por folios muy grandes distintos distintos por favor lo tenía por ahí he
pensado en subirlo sin más tampoco le deis mucha mucha historia vale otro que me gusta que ya lo
tenía hace hace días marcado lo he recortado es un paper de caos marques sabes que me gusta
mucho que habla del tema del porfolio ahora vamos a hablar un poco de todo esto vamos a hablar un
poco de todo esto porque hay distintas cosas vamos a explicar un poco ya cosas más de detalles de
práctica que son la teoría lo dije gente me dijo en el porfolio tras que acordó porque ya pensé
es una mezcla de práctica de teoría pero pensé que era mejor tratarlo más en la teoría lo vamos
a tratar hoy y si no dirá tiempo que creo que sí lo trataríamos el siguiente día vale pero aquí
habla un poco de porfolio es dilema ley de rudo rebalance es decir dejarlo correr o rebalancear
rebalancear es modificar los pesos cuando yo monto un porfolio lo monto en un momento concreto en el
tiempo vale pero eso hay que modificarlo y si lo modificó en base a qué criterio lo modificó
digamos que habla sobre sobre todo esto de acuerdo y hace un par de ejemplos y es interesante su
lectura entonces yo os lo voy a pasar como material que me parece interesante del curso
ahí lo dejo ahora que lo lees ahora vale y otro que lo podía subir el último día pero que lo
quiero subir hoy así tenéis tiempo de trabajar a leerlo si hay dudas demás uno que ya lo leí
hace bastante tiempo es del año es el año pasado si no recuerdo mal y bueno digamos que daba unos
consejos que de hecho algunos bueno nos compartan es que no los comparta es que todo depende del
lector a todo depende de para qué público lo dirijas pero pero no es que sea nada de lo que
dices mentira todo está perfecto todo está todo esto me acuerdo por si que nosotros por ejemplo
el punto uno no lo hacemos el dice no el uno no el 2 y se opera acciones sólo en el lado largo
por cierto con muy poco éxito en los últimos tiempos ahí está dicho y aquellos que nos
oyes en cada jueves en directo lo sabéis pero es verdad que es más difícil no es y de hecho
lo comenté en el curso lo comenté en el curso nos complique esa vida entrada si tú o sea yo
lo hago porque tengo que buscar alfa si yo lo perara para mi cuenta solo a lo mejor no lo
haría a lo mejor buscaría el alfa por otro lado pero pero yo al final tengo dos productos uno que
es por folio alfa y otro por folios marbeta y y por lo tanto claro alfa tiene que tratar de
aportar alfa la mayor alfa posible es ir corto de índices pero es difícil es difícil pues aquí
da algunos consejos muy útiles me gusta mucho en general de este este paper me gusta mucho
es un término en general y me gusta mucho no los vamos a leer todos aquí porque tampoco
hace falta ya los leeréis y si alguien quiere comentar algo entre alguna duda o incluso montar
podéis montar un debate entre vosotros si queréis en el bar o hacer preguntas en preguntas en el
discord pensando en el último día pero es realmente una serie de consejos muy muy interesantes
muy interesantes también habla del equal weighting por ejemplo ya lo había dicho de esto pero lo
vamos a ver a dos preferimos ir a igual igual weighting para mezclar las estrategias creemos
que es un camino bastante útil y bueno pues ya está ya lo ya lo ya lo leereis de acuerdo ya lo
leereis ahí os lo os lo de por cierto una de las cosas que dice es que el resulta que los sistemas
correlacionan mucho es decir que lo que depende más del resultado es el tipo de activo lo que
decía antes y ahí lo dejo también como el último material que os quería subir a no perdón me falta
otro me falta otro pero que va relacionado con maestro como ahora vamos a ver si tiene a bien
de cargar a que lo que tengo eso para abrirlo tiene bien de cargar algo de por folio maestro
par de cositas que os quiero enseñar vía vía maestro entonces bueno tengo tengo un manual que
es muy antiguo pero como maestro es súper antiguo hace hace más tiempo publicó 2016 por ahí incluso
antes no 2013 pero en 2013 publicó unos papers que explicaba sigue totalmente en vigor porque
es que no ha cambiado nada bueno yo diría que nada pero ha cambiado alguna pequeña cosa pero
pero debe ser insignificante insignificante es decir está totalmente en vigor por lo tanto estos
documentos que son de maestro porque creo que alguien me los había pedido os los os los subo
también aquí como un material de porfolio más para aquel que el tipo de archivo no válido perfecto
pues a ver espérate que lo voy a hacer si que así me lo me lo subirá porque la carpeta no la sube
y así va a ser más más más sencillo ha querido vale ya está eso sí más eso es para que él quiera
tener pues una cierta documentación de porfolio más encima se no tiene mayor utilidad si alguien
no quiere usar por folio maestro pues lo ignora y tan contentos vale venga y ahora vamos allá a ver
alguna a alguna cosita sobre alguna cosita sobre maestro y luego veremos sobre sobre por folio
trade por folio por folio bien antes quiero esto creo que ya lo puse ya lo puse como lo puse como
material en el poder por ahora vamos a hablar un poquito de ello porque es un ejemplo muy bueno
las semanas que quería haber podido enseñaros en las tripas de los porfolios pero no he conseguido
localizar esa información porque sólo di en una ponencia de robotrailer y no he conseguido
darlo a encontrarlo misterios de la tecnología pero sí quería igualmente hablaros hablaros
de ellos igualmente como para que entendáis bien el efecto del porfolio que os he comentado muchas
veces que no hace falta que no hace falta muchas veces tener un gran porfolio muchas veces estos
tres estrategias pueden ser eficientes porque eso mucha gente cuando empieza siempre le cuenta
como una barrera es muy complicado tener muchos sistemas nosotros hoy en día por distintos motivos
que la mayoría seguramente conocéis operamos dos familias de sistemas que cada una de ellas tienen
cuatro largos y cuatro cortos de tiro 8 8 versiones y que analizamos con ese excel que comentaba
antes me acuerdo que en correlaciones porque lógicamente hay que afinar mucho en la diversificación
sabemos es público y reconocido por nosotros que tiene camino de mejora el porfolio a nivel de
diversificación ahora vamos a tratar de abordarlo por tratar de mejorar aunque sabemos que la gran
mejora vendá cuando podamos usar futuros porque hay más más herramientas mejor mejor es igual o
no profundizamos pero aún así vamos a tratar de mejorar ahora en el ecosistema actual y queremos
poder poder conseguirlo pero pero como os digo para ver este para ver este en lo que os digo
de los de que se puede diversificar con uno mira para antes me lo voy a abrir esto en imagen
porque si no voy a estar todo el rato teniendo que volver alante y atrás y va a ser bastante
básico es lo que lo voy a abrir esto en imagen vale y cuando lo quiera mostrar pues lo muestro
directamente aquí en la imagen vamos a que la imagen lo puedo hacer grande pequeño y así no
tengo que ir todo el rato todo el rato pues yendo para adelante y para atrás en el porfolio vale
entonces al final el tema cuando yo tengo un solo sistema y por eso decimos muchas veces que es
una mejora el riesgo pero yo tengo aquí uno que ha ido muy bien que a los que tiene un
share de 0 38 es este de arriba y es el siguiente que tiene 0 14 más atentados en el share porque
es el que tenemos aquí vale que tenemos la diferencia de beneficio los dos tienen una
curva que no es que esté mal todos esos eran datos de operativas real todo y 38 el dimensionamiento
era tres reales pero dimensionados en nominal para este ejercicio y veis la gran diferencia de uno
y otro entonces hombre si yo cojo el primero perfecto el problema si cojo el segundo ahí está
el problema pero fijaros cómo cambia la mezcla de esos dos sistemas de acuerdo donde cómo se
amplifican y realmente acaban ganando mucho más la cartera con 2 que es la misma cartera es la
misma cartera pero al final en un porfolio donde se retroalimentan y donde hay diversificación
entre ellos diversifican al final juntos como veis consiguen un share de 0 45 muy superior al
primero y ganan mucho más que la suma de los dos eso es por el efecto diversificación de acuerdo
porque mejora por lo que mejora y esto puede chocar pero es así estos son datos son datos reales
está está está calculado se ha calculado si alguien por curiosidad para que si alguien
tiene es perspicaz verá que la suma de operaciones de 3 18 304 da 622 622 porque son los dos es
exactamente es recuerdos exactamente no hay no hay trampa ni cartón y fijaros cómo cambia el
sharp y cómo cambia y los dos empiezan con el mismo expectativa con el mismo capital lo que pasa
que al final cuando tú es un porfolio los dos sistemas se van retroalimentando y esa es la gracia
esa es la gracia por eso se permite esa mejora fijaros que realmente a partir de los dos
mejoramos súper poco la gran mejora es meter dos y esta es la reflexión que os quería llevar porque
se ve la tendencia no quiere decir que haya que operar dos esto porque podríamos haber encontrado
un mix mejor yo usado los mismos esto simplemente al final pasa porque hay dos tipos de sistema si
el tercero si el tercero fuera muy distinto mejoraría mucho más no pasa porque no lo es
más de acuerdo decir si yo el tercero yo ahora metiera aquí una artemisa de acuerdo pues iría
mejor porque hay que un nemesis de apolo y metido una artemisa pues seguramente mejoraría 0 60 por
0 50 y pico pero fijaros que al final aún así sí que consigo mejorar pero ya de manera más
residual de manera más residual la gran mejora la gran mejora en rentabilidad riesgo porque en
rentabilidad fijaros que no hay nada mejor que 2 los 2 vale porque al final lo que os he dicho
siempre la diversificar mejora el riesgo y puede mejorar los datos de retorno riesgo como aquí el
sean pero no normalmente no va a mejorar el retorno el que más gana es el de el de 2 el de 2 y eso si
lo veis aquí en gráficos esto ya lo vimos en la teoría pero son los mismos sistemas lo único que
el dimensionamiento pues provoca esa es efecto de provoca ese efecto provoca ese efecto pero
como os digo sólo metiendo 2 realmente conseguimos ya un efecto muy muy positivo por lo tanto esto
simplemente que sirva como reflexión que no pensar que necesita es una cartera con 20 sistemas
no es así vale no es así podéis trabajar con carteras de dos o tres sistemas y diversificarlos
bien si hay que trabajar bien ese concepto de diversificación es monetaria y este bien analizar
el riesgo que sean robustos sencillos pero con dos buenas estrategias podéis diversificarlos bien
lógicamente en lo que hemos visto que sería pues un tendencial y un mil reversión vale simplificando
un tendencial y un mil reversión y preferiblemente en activos distintos por ejemplo un mil reversión
en bolsa en lsp en el tax en vale y un tendencial en una materia prima petróleo oro gasolina carne
de vacuno zumo de naranja soja vale me interesa que os dé más rabia y esa y si luego metes tres
o cuatro y puedes ir diversificando pues uno en diario otra lo entraría perfecto pero para
empezar con un mil reversión y un tendencial en activos descorrelacionados si puede ser uno
más en diario y otro más en entraría tal vais a conseguir una cartera suficientemente eficaz eso
es lo que hemos hecho nosotros en dar un es en principio por sobre todo sobre todo como
sabéis por problemas de liquidez y demás pero ya digo que ahora vamos a tratar de abordar a ver
dónde metemos artemis para para mejorar porque con ese mix ya estaríamos todavía mejor pero
es verdad que nos gustaría mucho meter a nemesis en petróleo por ejemplo pero no un momento no
siguen aunque no cabía problemas de liquidez pero pero de esa manera podéis conseguir un
porfolio satisfactorio y más equilibrado de lo que creéis más equilibrado de lo que creéis
vale eso es y por donde que lo tengáis en cuenta bien aquí hemos hecho hoy un par de pruebas con
ese porfolio de sí o realidad son los sistemas que operan así o en los últimos 10 años toda
operativa son sets que han operado todos en no el 100% de los que se han operado por sus
que han operado todos esto como veis hemos probado bastante pobre el hemos tocado un poco
el money management y realmente porque tiene años en la primera parte un poco flojos en años poco
flojos 2014 es donde está ahí la parte la parte final pero simplemente quería que vierais curvas
las curvas operativas reales se parecen más a esto que a las que salen de bactés pero también
quería que vierais un poco a lo que os digo que un porfolio evidentemente no es lo ideal y aquí
pues tenemos estrategias que están algunas de ellas algunas de ellas se van a ser bueno
pero va a ser revisado ahora todo el porfolio pero pero hay alguna que estaba justita justita
ya os lo he comentado en los directos está justitado esto ahí va y ahí tenéis por ejemplo
un ejemplo vale esto es un porfolio con aquí 14 estrategias y habéis que hay varias que están
perdiendo y algunas de ellas prácticamente casi ni han estado han estado ganando seguramente son
cortos lo que os digo las cortas de bolsa ha ido bastante mal
tenemos que darles una vuelta importante a ellas hemos que darles una buena importante
demasiado tiempo demasiado tiempo sufriendo vale y aún así aún así a pesar de habiéndote estando
con obtener ahora estrategias que en el pasado no han ido bien esto lógicamente no quiere decir
que es todo lo que hemos operado que son los sets son los sets que de hecho no son ni los que
están ahora 100% operando los que seguramente elegimos aquí para entendernos vale que dijimos
aquí o un poco antes puede ser un ejemplo de un porfolio que he mirado antiguo y que lo he
actualizado pero esto no lo hemos operado todo así pero pero simplemente os lo enseño para que
veáis esta reflexión aquí hay varias estrategias perdedoras y camisa curva es positiva esa curva
ha ganado dinero que no ha ganado mucho dinero bueno no ha ganado mucho dinero es verdad dinero
teniendo varias estrategias que lo han perdido lo han perdido no es que han ganado poco han perdido
dinero y esto es lo que hablaba en algunos medios broma medio en serio la teoría cuando decía el
santo creado es el porfolio vale este esto es de acuerdo esto es este efecto acuerdo este efecto
solo lo vas a conseguir con un porfolio porque tú nunca vas a saber si qué estrategia vas a elegir
lógicamente vas a intentar elegirla muy buena pero y aquí en este ejemplo que hemos puesto antes
lógicamente hemos puesto un ejemplo por lo que mente es que habían ido bien pero podría haber
sido una perdedora como has visto como has visto ahora en el otro porfolio en cambio con la mezcla
has conseguido que el porfolio gane dinero a pesar de esas estrategias claro si hubieras cogido la
buena perfecto pero si coges la mala entiendes ahí está siempre el problema vale bien en cuanto al
dimensionamiento aquí maestro es un programa que es un desastre muchas cosas pero tiene alguna que
nos gusta mucho que nos gusta mucho que veis el drag down que está bastante bastante bien
ecualizado bastante bien ecualizado en los entornos del 25% y una cosa que nos gusta mucho de esto es
ver este gráfico pero si no tienes que calcular en excel y demás y esto es la exposición de
lo que os decía antes tenemos una exposición en el lado largo máxima de 2.7 aproximada y abajo
de 2.1 vale esto está usando nuestro algoritmo el que os enseñé el otro día y veis el efecto
que provoca porque tiene siempre ese efecto arriba techo es por el límite inferior de acuerdo es el
límite inferior lo que provoca eso porque yo en el momento en que en el momento en que la
volatilidad baja demasiado no le dejo que exponga más ahí le pongo un tope que no sé si recordáis
que era hablo de memoria del orden del 175 por ejemplo en apolo nasdaq vale pues si llega a
eso automáticamente implica un multiplicador por el nominal porque es una constante una constante
se va a variar en base al precio el nominal pero no va a variar por volatilidad por lo tanto acaba
siendo un multiplicador del precio es decir el nominal en ese gráfico se ve muy claro si yo voy
a nominal lo que veríais es todo el rato una línea recta es esto todo el rato así aquí como no es
nominal puro que es que es nominal pues ajustado en cambio si yo ahora lo que pasa que vamos a
hacer una cosa porque lo veáis que lo ves esto esto ahora no lo voy a poner los años porque
podemos morir en el intento podemos podemos no por bloquear como no va a usar muchos procesadores
no no va a bloquear nada simplemente para para que veáis el gráfico pero lo que voy a hacer es
bloquear lo que o sea quitar el límite quitar el límite de el tope este quitar el tope se lo voy
a poner 0 lo que no lo veo lo que no lo veo ha filtrado aterrero pero si le pongo 0 no va a
actuar no me va a llevar mucho cero cero cero cero cero cero cero cero cero cero cero cero cero cero
porque al final es un max size y pondrá el que el que le dé el de gestión monetaria dará un
número y pondrá ese por lo tanto podrá balancarse más porque eso va el riesgo van el denominador
acordaros recordáis de la clase pasada a ver esto ahora bueno a lo mejor me dejó alguno pero es
igual me deja alguno los otros se van a mover igual y fíltate aquí fíltate fíltate es fíltate
si fíltate fíltate fíltate fíltate entonces vais a ver vais a ver lo que pasa puede ser que se
gane más es decir no os penséis que de hecho es probable es probable que gane más es probable
que sea más volante aquí no puede ser me tengo que haber saltado aquí está toca haber saltado
sin marcar aquí estos en el oro cuesta más porque es más pequeño es 021 se lo podría
haber pasado con variable global ahora no son generado a ver todo lo podíamos hacer con
variable más que nada para no tener que meterlo en todos vale a ver ahora qué pasa ahora qué pasa
ahora estaría trabajando está trabajando y ya pues podemos ir a dar una vuelta así bueno
simplemente para que veáis ese tema luego cuando acabe esto vale también os enseñaré
para que ya lo habéis visto de una manera sencilla una manera sencilla de para los
enseñar dos trucos para para más avanzados y para menos por un lado para los más avanzados
tanto por folio maestro como por folio trader vale hay algunas librerías y algunas de revelanzeo
porque maestro tiene opciones de revelanzear que si alguien las quiere que me las pida porque no
sé si están por defecto la verdad que tengo dudas pero hay unas hay una serie de palabras
reservadas de funciones que creo que no vienen instaladas creo que estaban en los foros que
permiten controlar el por folio por ejemplo calcular el money management coger la cuenta
del por folio de acuerdo pasa que eso hay que hacerlo con objetos es una estrategia que lo hace
que usa esa esa es la función es la función y eso por ejemplo es una estrategia que lo usa
hay que meter el objeto y tal pues eso es un poco avanzado no no quiero complicaros
complicaros la vida porque la única diferencia de esto es que yo puedo referirme a datos del
por folio en vez de sólo del sistema que yo cuando hago un sistema me estoy refiriendo a
los datos del sistema yo quiero referirme a datos del por folio pues lo tengo que hacer de esta
manera tengo que usar este tipo de funciones como por folio maestro profit risk como por folio maestro
fix it fractional pues esto nosotros pues lo tenemos algunas versiones de los sistemas que
usan estas palabras y pasan el riesgo a través de este cálculo simplemente para usar la equity del
por folio es la única diferencia que pasamos el riesgo de cada sistema pero usamos la equity del
por folio y hasta aquí te lo te lo explica y estos son palabras reservadas también por folio
multicharts tiene este hecho hasta tiene más y es un poco lo mismo simplemente para referirte
a datos del por folio en conjunto el sistema en sí tiene datos del mismo si quiero usar
datos del por folio pues tengo que usarlo como digo con este tipo de palabras de palabras
reservadas vale esta es la manera podemos decir más avanzadas también hay para referirse a esto
de allocate and rebalancer por qué porque tres multicharts que ahora perdón maestro que es muy
breve ahora en 5 10 minutos aunque yo se da los los por los pdfs os lo voy a enseñar porque eso
sí que a nivel de acciones por ejemplo sistemas de rotacionales que alguien preguntaba puede tener
su utilidad vale pero sobre todo ya digo para nada optimizar y demás porque más todo eso es
inviable esto es lo que he tardado ahora he acabado de hacer sólo el backtest vale y ahora he hecho
este mismo backtest vale le he quitado el límite le he quitado el límite y no sé si ha ido mejor o
peor ha ido peor no ha ganado bastante pero bastante peor bastante peor vale ah bueno no
pero son menos años no no no no es que ha ido peor es que son menos años o menos años que
después son muchos menos años era era sólo para que verais esto veis ahora ya no hay límite
ahí está ahora es ahora el límite es distinto porque porque yo ahora no le he hecho un tope
ahora está se llega a palancar 405 vez aquí se ha palancado siete veces porque porque no había
volatilidad esto esto ahora alguien lo preguntaba es persen volatilidad de acuerdo es persen
volatilidad y con el cálculo propio de volatilidad usando el atr normalizado vale con lo que quieras
pero al final es por volatilidad es decir cuando hay poca volatilidad meto mucho cuando hay más
volatilidad meto menos es la diferencia este es el efecto que provoca poner un límite en la parte
baja esto así se ve muy bien vale que al cuando actúa el límite estoy yendo a un multiplicador
el nominal no es que vaya al 100% nominal voy a 2.7 voy aún aún a una exposición bastante
estable con relación al nominal del activo sea acciones sea futuros lo que sea cuando hay
volatilidad entonces baja y puede llegar a niveles muy bajos como es aquí que cuando es esto pues el
cobit 2020 veces ese pico ahí debajo es el cobit donde la exposición baja pues mucho aquí no hay
como baja porque ahí está el cobit también bajan en el otro decir en el otro también ha bajado la
diferencia no es que no baje el otro sino que el otro sube más el otro ahí también en el cobit
si yo aquí busco el cobit este cargo a menos no he cargado el cobit bueno que le he puesto menos
antes para que fuera más rápido no le he puesto el cobit pero bueno ya veis que aquí hay más
volatilidad aquí en esa parte más volatilidad y aquí en esa parte menos volatilidad mercado más
esto se entiende verdad eso se entiende lo que tengo marcado vale juan comenta juan le he leído
primero para comenta juan que se cara al portfolio si por ejemplo tenemos 20 sistemas estudiados con
ópticos médicas etcétera que son viables pero sólo queremos o podemos elegir 10 entiendo que
por un tema de capital que menos correlación la teoría se mostró la matiz de excel de correlaciones
comentó que se vería realmente la parte vale bueno no era consciente que dijera dijera esto pero
ahora te lo enseño ahora te lo enseño es que esto esto al final simplemente es una tu ahí lo que lo
que yo haría en este caso es un poco por donde iba este documento que os he enseñado antes muy
sencillo es decir ahí que deberías de hacer por un lado deberías de elegir por un lado vale si
tienes 20 no metamos porquería el porfolio luego habrá cosas que serán porquería porque porque
nos habíamos equivocado vale puede pasar pero digo de entrada no metamos porfolio normalmente
tú vas a tener sistemas que los ves mejor es decir que son tus grandes sistemas evidentemente
esos van entonces si tú de verdad tienes 20 que los 20 son top entonces empezamos a hablar
pero si no elige los los que de verdad concibidas que son más top y cuando digo más top no quiero
decir que ganen más sean más robustos por ejemplo que es un sistema robusto antes en ese documento
que se ha pasado cauma también lo ponía que es un sistema robusto un sistema que tiene muchos que
variar que las pruebas de sensibilidad que los mapas que tiene muchas zonas de trabajo eso es
un muy buen sistema y que da confianza si tú tienes 20 así perfecto entonces ahora ahora te
contesto pero no creo que tengas 20 así entonces si no tienes 20 así elige los que son así elige
los que son así los que son de ese tipo los que son súper robustos sencillos vale no necesariamente
los que ganan más eso es lo tentador oye si es el que gana más y además robusto entonces perfecto
pero me entiendes no siempre más seguridad que el rendimiento calidad más que calidad en el
sentido de robustez bien entonces si tienes 20 de este tipo vale entonces ahí el criterio siempre
es correlación correlación y ahí es donde entra la matriz donde entra la matriz yo estoy prácticamente
seguro que la teoría lo hice un poco lo de desgostar la matriz pero de todas maneras entiendo que es
un tema interesante la mayoría de programas para la mayoría de programas en este caso tanto maestro
como como un porfil que ahora vamos a ir a él ahora vamos a ir a él te lo va a enseñar cuando
cualquier problema que gestione por folios evidentemente una de las informaciones que
te da es correlaciones de los miembros porque es que es de cajón vale en el caso de maestro lo
tienes en análisis tienes aquí correlación análisis tú le eliges el porfolio este último
que hemos mirado por ejemplo le dices por símbolo por estátese y group en este caso esto es un
detalle ahora no vale la pena para el tiempo le pongo éxtrate bueno en este caso va a ser lo
mismo porque sólo hay dos estátese y groups que son de símbolos distintos en este caso no importa
y lo puedes hacer bien diario y mensual aquí cuando ya le coges algo ya lo calcula así que
ahora lo está calculando diario si lo quiero cambiar a mensual pues lo cálculo y lo calcula
y aquí tienes todas las métricas de las correlaciones lógicamente hay algunos como ya
os os comenté que son muy parecidos pero eso siempre es mejor si son robustos que tener el
mismo set y los son muy distintos largos cortos vale entre oros entre ellos mismos son largos
y cortos pero también entre entre apolos y oros como veis pues están entre 0 1 2 0 menos algo
es un poco buenas correlaciones cerca de 0 pero menos de 0 5 ya estamos diversificando
obviamente 0 8 0 9 diversificar muy poco muy poco casi nada pero entonces tú ahí elegirías esos
elegirías los que mejor correlación te dé y eso partiendo de lo que te decía en la entrada si tú
tienes distintos sistemas distintos activos tienes que tener ahí una selección previa que era un
poco por donde iba este documento que ellos por aquí de porfolio como hoy es que no era más que
un ejemplo un ejemplo aplicable a todo es decir yo tengo unos grupos hay autores por ejemplo creo
que era un que reconoce que creo que tiene 4 o 5 tipos y está correcto o sea tú tienes equity
bolsa tienes tipos de interés vale y luego dentro de materias primas hablando de futuros
dentro de materias primas pues tienes distintos tipos aquí las que entran tibisas energías
tienes granos tienes plan de soft financieras tienes distintas entonces ahí tú puedes ir
eligiendo metales no que no acabe energía entonces al final pues vas un poco por categoría si todas
las tienes de equity pues bueno pues ya regular la cosa entiendes que tienes que elegir pero es
mejor elegir de categoría distinta que es repetir entonces si puedes poner una de equity otra de
interés de tipos intereses otra de metales otra de energía y otra de granos es perfecto entiendes
ese sería un criterio eso normalmente ya en esta matriz te va a salir así pero si por lo que fuera
no te saliera en caso de duda lo decides así entiendes en caso de duda lo decides así es decir
los vas metiendo por distinta categoría vale porque partiene y cuando digo categoría cuidado
ahora te ha hablado de ahora te ha hablado de activos porque es el documento que te había enviado
pero es mucho más importante por estrategia que por activo antes vale primer criterio es estrategia
y luego activo es decir si tú tienes buen estrategia o sea buenas de este tipo que te he dicho yo
súper estable súper robustos y tienes un tendencial en el nasa y otro antitencial en el
sp y cumplen estos dos criterios que te he dicho que son robustos es mejor que opere esos dos
siendo los dos equity que operar un oro y un nasdaq siendo el del oro malo entiendes
más importante por estrategia pero lo ideal lógicamente es las dos cosas decir en nasdaq
sp y tendencia en oro tendencia a ir combinándolo en uno diario lo que entraría a ser combinado
eso es lo ideal lo ideal como no normalmente esto que al final es el sentido común que como he
dicho todo el curso es en la vida es importante eso es y lo comentaba el otro día hacía una
charla con con un colega y le decía eso es verdad o sea hoy y lo comentaba también el curso si
hablando de broma de ya no te cuento de fútbol o sea de o de política o sea al final tú piensa
la cantidad de cosas que tenemos todos la misma información y de esa misma información se generan
opiniones radicalmente distintas que no digo opiniones perdón conclusiones radicalmente
distintas es porque hay muchos sesgos vale entonces los datos para el final saber decidir y tratar de
no tener sesgos por eso en el curso hablé una parte de sesgos es muy importante en un análisis
de datos es muy importante esto pasa mucho por ejemplo en un tema súper científico que lo puse
este ejemplo como tema del covid es ciencia pura es es pura ciencia la epidemiología es pura
ciencia y virus pero ciencia pura y la epidemiología es pura ciencia toda probabilidad es estadística
absoluta el por ciento lo estudié bastante a nivel y a nivel de aficionado y hay gente que con esos
mismos datos dice que que no funciona no que se funciona o gente que ahora ha descubierto que los
medicamentos tienen efectos secundarios no sabía que la gente hay gente que se ha muerto por tomar
una aspirina gente que no lo sabe pero yo ya os lo digo todos los medicamentos del mundo tienen
efectos secundarios a finales y sesgos falta de información etcétera entiendes y esto pasa en
todos los análisis de datos pues imagínate imagínate con sistemas imagínate con sistemas pasa
igual entonces al final los datos se van a dar información pero también a veces los sesgos
de cariña sistema este es mío este tal este me gusta más este medio muy bien entonces hay que
tratar de ser lo más frío lo más estéril posible por eso también os doy pautas podemos decir que
no son puramente de datos como os digo no primero por el sistema y muy importante la estrategia
distinta es el vector más importante sin duda alguna de verdad o sea es el más importante
también frame distinto activo distinto etcétera vale y por supuesto matriz de correlaciones y
aquí pues tienes que alcanzarlas esto tú te lo puedes llevar a excel puedes ver qué tiene cada
uno con todos los demás puedes hacer promedios puedes trabajar lo estadísticamente no hay más
no hay mucho secreto en ese sentido o sea no hay nada en ningún cálculo especial que puedas
hacer es una tabla de correlaciones cada uno contra todos y ahí sale no hay más vale aureli
añade este ese tema no a añadir que de que dice juan que cuál es el valor de correlación con
se verás que es muy correlacionado y creo que hablaste también ya lo contestado que vas para
también más o menos si esto es mensual esto aureli que has visto lo puedes poner en términos
mensuales de términos diarios bueno míralo en los dos lo normal lo normal es que hay datos
muy similares lo normal es que hay datos muy similares hay autores que defienden que mejor
diario y autores con datos que hizo una práctica con excel que muy trabajada con datos que la verdad
recomiendo verla bastantes veces es tensa de narices ya que hice horas con el excel que si tal
diario tal ulcer trabajé mucho ahí en los datos y viste entonces bueno pueden cambiar dos diarios
mensuales hay cosas el diario siempre tiene mucho más detalle más de diario no evidentemente pero
ya no tiene mucho más mucho más detalle el mensual a veces pierde cosas pero pero normalmente
es suficiente vale normalmente lo que hablamos siempre de un equilibrio entre productividad
otra más detalle más cuesta más más cantidad de información entonces siempre hay que tener un
equilibrio está bien mirarlo por tal pero normalmente no vas a obtener lecturas muy distintas
normalmente no vas a obtener lecturas muy distintas ante sobre todo en correlaciones diarias o demás
muy interesante luego el efecto mensual hay gente que también lo mide en drawdowns o ratos de
pérdidas mensuales es correcto lo normal y lo fácil es mirar rendimientos rendimientos como
este caso vale pero otra manera que hay bastante sencilla y visual si no quieres sacar datos o
el programa te los saca ya lo hemos comentado al final lo que a mí me interesa más la
descorreglación es por las pérdidas más que por las ganancias entonces desde ese punto de vista
así que puede venir bien a mejor mirar pérdidas diarias los días malos que no coincidan y ahí sí
que te puede venir bien la correlación en diaria te puede dar más ese detalle y luego incluso
pues ver ya te digo los días malos donde son puedes ver cuáles son los peores días de ese
sistema cuando fueron en uno en otro que no sean en el mismo año el mismo mes tienes eso sí que
es un detalle que puede venir bien el caso sobre todo de duda no de elegir uno u otro porque al
final a mí me interesa por eso vale yo aquí ahora por ejemplo en este aquí no lo puedo ver lo puedo
ver probablemente luego en cada el informe de cada sistema puedo ver cuando tiene el trabajo pero
yo aquí sí que me enseña en maestro por ejemplo el detalle de cada uno de ellos como habéis visto
antes entonces pero no puedo ver el trabajo de cada uno de ellos de aquí podría haberlo
hay una opción para sacar la curva de cada sistema es que se puede cuando haces el informe
entonces a mí a mí lo que me interesa es ver eso a la hora de elegir que es lo ideal pues que vayan
distintos pero pero lógicamente ganando es el problema que también en esta época aquí aquí
puedes decir esto seguro que no que no sirven bueno seguro seguro habría que verlo hay que
verlo porque al final bueno en su tipo de mercado su tipo de mercado no se han aportado en algunos
momentos si os fijáis aquí no digo que eso sea correcto para que me entendáis fijaros por ejemplo
aquí vale todo el de los los los buenos no los directores claramente parece que van a la baja
no en cambio eso es mira entonces aquí de hecho hay un momento hasta que se acercan porque diversificaban
realmente estos han estado cumpliendo su labor es que sería mejor que lo hicieron ganando
pero me entendéis no es el efecto la diversificación es ese claro es lo ideal es que todos ganen pero
hay veces que depende el tipo de mercado pero nos pierden y no necesariamente quiere decir
que eso es malo que mirarlo hay que analizarlo que trabajarlo y tratar de que ganen pero dices
que no puedes de hecho que hay alguno que nos acaba de ver a ver si esto me lo marca y a este
que ha sido aquí un desastre a los ahora donde está lo veis se ve un poco espera a lo mejor un
color porque ese es un buen ejemplo que yo lo había visto antes donde era esto de los colores
aquí si alguna paleta que me pone ese otro color nos supone 50 horas de procesamiento eso es muy
interesante de verlo si pensará este rojo que se ve un poco más con la vista previa
la vista previa creo que se veía bastante bien bandera print preview vamos si muy bien el color
de coña se ve de coña sí sí sí sí sí vaya vaya maravilla maravilla y eso porque se ha quedado
de ese color no no no no ya veo que lo tengo ya lo veo pero no sé por qué no sé por qué
a veces por la impresora seleccionada que está una impresora a ver pero a ver si le doy a que
primero va a imprimir a todo el mundo no sé por qué está puesta la impresora debe estar puesta
pero es que no se ponía aquí esto no me acuerdo no me acuerdo lo hecho a veces a veces aquí aquí
ahora ahora ahora ahora ahora ahora ahora ahora aplicar ahora canceló el preview 2 con el programa
venga perfecto bueno pues nada igual lo he intentado pero no sé por qué porque ahora he cogido
cambiada impresora no no es que no lo ha cambiado a ver se ha pasado de mí tengo que hacer imprimir
si no no y allá el recorte pantalla podría ser pero es que esto lo he hecho otras veces no sé ahora
porque no ha quedado por defecto ya sé porque ya sé porque ya sé porque ya sé porque porque
antes he hecho el pdf creator se ha quedado como impresora por defecto en el sistema y coger el
sistema ya verás como es eso aquí está no pues pues está como predeterminada pues esperar está
colgado no se ha quedado y colgado nos creéis que es que no quiero se ha quedado printing y ahí está
bueno bueno se ve un poco no se ve un poco no puedo ver nada entonces fijaros que ese ha sido
el peor en más antes momentos y ahora pues ha remontado muchísimo está entre los mejores
pero de este grupo peor ha llegado casi a ser de los mejores y el rojo fijaros que estable no por
ejemplo lo veis no la diferencia ahí se ven se ven cosas luego hay algunos pues que como este
gris que bueno en ningún momento parece que ha dado la talla pero o este mismo aquí fíjate que
está el peor es el verde aquí en la zona de 22 donde tengo el rato ahora aquí fijaros que llega
si no que ha cancelado pero no nos ha cancelado fijaros que está ahí arriba el todo ahora está
entre los mejores esto es lo que se busca al final no es al final sólo con las dos familias
para que veáis que con dos familias hemos conseguido una investigación satisfactoria que
es mejorable si es totalmente es totalmente de hecho estamos en ello ahora sí ahora sí ahora le
ha cogido la la printing ahora yo creo que ahora yo creo que va a funcionar pero yo creo que va a
funcionar va a funcionar ahora vas a ver tú cómo funciona ahí lo tienes pero sí pero aquí
esto de abajo a coño vale vale pero ahora me acuerdo me acuerdo puedo quitar la leyenda
una paciencia con esto ahora se ve se ve un poco se ve un poco mejor un poco mejor tiene el fondo
blanco se ve un poco mejor lo que pasa que también es bastante mejorable pero bueno
todavía mejor en este peso que lo que os decía no aquí lo que lo que os decía de este aquí es
este de aquí y no sé si lo veis que ahora está aquí está aquí os decía el rojo también no
fijaros todo el tiempo el rojo que es bastante estable en un momento llega abajo tampoco es
nada tal entonces es un poco la idea no por lo que os decía también del azul no este verde aquí
fijaros que aquí llega a estar por un momento es el peor de todos mirando nuestra hora este es un
poco lo que lo que os digo del efecto diversificador y también este azul aquí al revés el otro azul
destacando aquí y mirar mirar mirar es este no es este es este es este es este es este entonces
al final bueno esto es la diversificación que lo ideal es que diversifique consiguiendo yendo
por ejemplo esta diversificación de aquí es ideal no está mirando es aquí este hay
los logos pero ha habido un verde que mirar que ha llegado a él ha llegado ha hecho perfecto y
de estar muy abajo le ha remontado totalmente eso es lo ideal en cambio aquí veis el rosa que
había que se ve se ha tapado desde todos pero fíjate aquí estaba y se ha quedado ahí parado
el más estable sin caer mucho entonces estos han caído el rosa parece que no ha caído bueno si
parece que estaba aquí también entonces este es luego también los que han ido mal todo el gato
habrá que revisar seguramente este es el efecto y esos son dos familias de sistemas que operan
oro y nasdaq un tendencial y una tendencial sólo es con distintos sets distintas zonas de trabajo
entonces está con dos y idealmente os diría yo que con tres con tres se puede conseguir muy buen
trabajo de verdad con tres se puede conseguir muy buen trabajo había alguna más por ahí
bueno está de 20 no sé cómo es como lo desmarcas yo salverto como se desmarca la
pregunta porque a mí me sale ahí para la prioridad a no poder responderla ha hecho
hay que ponerle le pongo hecho pero no me responde no me ha salido pero yo le he puesto
hecho y no lo ha quitado no sé si habría alguna herramienta en por ejemplo más para
comprar los sistemas y ver cuál funciona mejor con otro para comparar entiendo que dices no bueno
si esto es todo esto que estamos viendo es para comparar sistemas de cierto aquí hay más pestañas
vale el tema es que él es muy lento de procesamiento pero yo aquí puedo poner por ejemplo los dos activos
que ha habido puedo ver distintas distintas cosas para analizar distintas pruebas los de la
hora hay bastante información hay cosas interesantes en los gráficos también a nivel de información
está bastante bien el problema es que es muy lento pero la información que genera los informes está
muy bien lo que os decía antes vale para acabar brevemente en maestro me voy a por folio 3 vale
os decía antes que habían varias maneras en el mone y manas menos he dicho algunas avanzadas y
demás también en maestro maestro tiene incorporado un módulo de mone y manas menis ranqueo cuando ya
ya mira en su mano cuando tienes el strategy group yo cada strategy group le puedo asignar por
ejemplo teníamos este de ruptura de acciones vale le asignó un sistema le asignó pues unos unas
acciones y le puedo asignar una gestión monetaria vale esto creo que está explicado se ha explicado
básicamente está fix el fractional y fixate amount per price que viene a ser como una especie
de delta entonces yo puedo aquí ya probar alguna cosa puedo ponerle una cantidad fija y demás vale
y luego esto del ranking que es muy interesante para esto en línea con lo que hablaba antes
no recuerdo quién de los rotacionales yo aquí puedo elegir un ranqueo por ejemplo por performance
por person change lo que sube el activo aquí se configura esto ya digo puedes usar la ayuda o
aquellos pdfs que os he dado os pueden ayudar vale yo puedo decirle que coja un n número de activos
sobre la lista imaginas que aquí tengo la lista del nasa 100 pues yo puedo ranquear esto es lo que
lo que hablábamos antes puede decir cada mes o cada día de cada mes por y por varios criterios
se puede importar por un excel que lo importas se puede hacer por varios criterios para los
criterios ya digo no perdemos el tiempo porque es muy concreto quien lo quiera pues que lo
explore al final simplemente que os explico lo que hace es ranquear se permite elegir un
número es otro sistema aparte del sistema que se encarga de elegir cuántas acciones normalmente
porque se hace más con acciones sobre una lista de lo él elige y le puedo poner todo el sb 500
pero solo elige las 20 que cumplen ese determinado criterio y a y cambiarlo cada mes es lo que es un
rotacional esto maestro lo permite lo permite hacer y también tiene por código como os decía antes
tiene alguno por código aquí esto lo usa el dato de ranking y tal y lo puede elegir por
código entonces un poco avanzado pero simplemente como antes lo había comentado alguien lo
tiene el ranking y tiene money management están ahí los pdfs luego también pues
puedes recogir la ayuda de maestro que también está más o menos aquí ver un poquito las las
distintas opciones esto está aquí en los más que un porfolio en está tejido aquí está tejido
pues es por ejemplo money management aquí te las explica y también te es lo de el ranking ahora
cuando lo vea aquí está realmente los pdfs aquí te explica un poco cómo funciona el ranking
los cientos que hay como algunos de ejemplo no están todos explicados la mayoría así vale no
es propiamente objeto pero quería comentarlo para que lo para que lo es vale bien vamos ahora aquí
a ver también por folio trader algunas cosas las voy comentando a las voy comentando porque
están un poco a caballo entre entre teoría y práctica ahí en ese documento que se ha pasado
antes de caos man fijaros que aborda el detalle de rebalancear o no rebalancear que es lo que no es
exactamente esto que hablamos ahora me refiero al nivel de los pesos de los porfolios ahí habéis
visto en maestro por ejemplo una lista una una cartera pero yo ahí no he rebalanceado si lo quiero
rebalancear y quiero probar eso lo debería haber hecho por código no lo he hecho en porfolio trader
estoy un poco en la misma situación una cosa es montar un porfolio y ver a ver qué exposición le
pongo como puedo ver ahí pero yo tengo que tomar nuevamente una decisión que aunque nadie creo que
específicamente lo preguntados lo comento igual es qué pesos doy de inicio de acuerdo eso es una
pregunta que frecuentemente se encuentra un trader y como siempre como siempre hay varias
posibles respuestas de acuerdo esa es una y luego rebalancear o no rebalancear de acuerdo al final
recordar ya os lo dije en la teoría y en algunos momentos de la práctica lo más comentado también
ahora y al ver el documento este que os decía de de kauffman hablaba del equal weighted vale al final
nominal por ejemplo no deja de ser un equal weighted cuando hablamos de equal weighted es la clave es
por qué criterio se ecualiza es decir equal weighted es el mismo peso a cada uno pero el mismo peso
de que denominal mismo peso es el mismo stop el mismo peso es el mismo dinero en bruto el mismo
peso es el mismo riesgo por volatilidad bueno todo esto son respuestas posibles de la pregunta
de acuerdo respuestas posibles yo os puedo decir lo que a nosotros nos gusta más de acuerdo que
es como que es lo mismo que existe en el mónio manás menos por volatilidad de acuerdo es decir
equal weighted por volatilidad vale que si no recuerdo mal es lo que apuntaba también en este pdf
bueno no sé si así que no era que ese es el eso se ha recortado ya la parte es aquí
bueno fijaros que hablaba de hablaba del porfolio fijaros aquí por ejemplo que os dirá poco lo que
decía el porfolio y por ejemplo un divisas nasdaq no es repartido no es repartido que
revisa el porfolio es si si él el usaba volatilidad el usaba volatilidad para repartir es decir al
final reparte el mismo peso pero a por volatilidad es decir al final cómo haces eso pues como lo
hacemos nosotros metiéndolo el risk o sea el componente risk al final por eso decimos que la
y el porfolio van totalmente conectados y acordaros que yo os decía maneras de controlar el riesgo
hasta otra exposición y otra diversificación exposición mone y management diversificación
por folio pero van conectados porque porque yo al final decido con el mone management la exposición
de cada sistema pero luego también lo tengo que decir a decir había de porfolio por eso os decía
el porfolio al final es lo mismo como sistema y al final de un sistema analizo las métricas
analizo la gestión monetaria pues lo mismo pasa en el porfolio y al final lo tengo que llevar a
una plataforma sea msa sea maestro sea por folio trader que las tres las habéis visto y ahí analizar
en conjunto los datos que obtengo pero es verdad que tengo que tomar alguna decisión que es la de
inicio que os decía en caso de duda podéis recurrir al clásico pero no por ello menos útil
múltiplo del drawdown de acuerdo este es un criterio bastante conocido y cómodo y es útil
y práctico y es eficiente para decidir el capital asignar a un sistema si yo tengo un
sistema que tiene un drawdown de 10.000 euros pues yo sé que una manera típica que se puede
repartir el capital inicial es dos veces el dragón más las garantías aquí cuidado más que deciros
dos veces os digo n veces n veces porque depende mucho de que dragón hablemos si hablamos de un
dragón de operativas real hablamos un dragón del sistema optimizado hablamos el dragón de monte
carlo claro entonces depende un dragón de monte carlo pues probablemente no hace falta ya darle
mucho más margen si si no proviene de unos datos sobre optimizados pero ahí todo todo ya dependerá
de nuestra calidad de procesos de nuestro rigor en el análisis de la robustez en todo esto que si
yo presento datos muy sobre optimizados me estoy haciendo trampas al solitario y al final pues el
dragón va a ser mentira la mejoranza lo multiplico por dos y hasta es poco entonces ahí ya depende
un poco por eso decimos n veces el dragón puede ser una ser dos entonces es un criterio que es
útil clásico pero que es muy muy funcional para iniciar el portfolio para iniciar el portfolio es
decir yo asigno capital esa manera otra manera no mala es simplemente por volatilidad es decir el
que hemos hecho nosotros en maestro simplemente yo asigno un porcentaje de repartido por por familia
de sistema y luego entre familias los reparto partes iguales lo puedo repartir a partes iguales
pero cada uno ya ecualiza y reparte esa parte igual es por unidad de riesgo el cálculo por el
que saca los lotes depende de la volatilidad pero como todos utilizan el mismo todos utilizan el
mismo ratio volatilidad con límites mínimos y máximos pues de esa manera yo ya ecualizo bien el
porfolio esta es una una una respuesta que os puedo dar a cómo empezar luego a nivel de análisis
de métricas bueno aquí un poco aplica lo mismo que el sistema recordaros que os hablé en el
porfolio os hablé de la teoría de carteras os hablé de la teoría de que es también conocida
media varianza la teoría clásica de carteras en donde proviene sharp eso es la teoría media
varianza varianza y hablamos también de la teoría posmoderna no que era tema de sortino el upside
ratio que también hizo un vídeo ahí bastante extenso toda esa parte partes densas que recomiendo
verlas varias veces y ahí pues hablamos también del bar del c bar el tema del bar c bar es
tremendamente útil a mí me gusta mucho pero más que no hay muchas plataformas que lo extraigan
directamente o sea que ya te lo den entonces al final ya entramos en complejidad de cálculo
yo os lo enseñé en excel porque nosotros cuando lo calculamos lo que hablamos que realmente no nos
lo dan no nos lo dan ni maestro ni al final los que uséis python pues pues perfectamente
calculártelo vale y yo os lo recomiendo recomiendo calcularos el c bar aquellos que como os digo
trabajéis vía python os recomiendo trabajar el c bar y trabajar con esas estimaciones por folio
lo que os digo igual pero medir el análisis el fitness no la función objetivo que yo puedo
analizar puedo usar c bar si no podemos seguir con sortino o incluso con sharp no es ninguna
migración a mí sobre todo a nivel de portfolio a mí me gusta más sortino ya lo dije no es
ninguna migración sea no es ninguna migración más que tiene sus defectos y que es verdad que
los retornos no están normalmente distribuidos ya lo sabemos y demás pero al final para hacer
una comparación de volatilidad no es no es absurdo porque es verdad que sabemos que muchas veces la
volatilidad al alza acababa devolviendo me acuerdo pero es verdad que eso viene mucho de los activos
clásicos porque en una cartera diversificada no tiene porque vale pero de ahí de ahí de ahí plora
la criatura que decimos en catalán no de ese concepto de que lo que sube mucho luego también
baja no por eso al final considera la volatilidad buena mala toda no que a mi sorteo no considera
la volatilidad bala sólo la parte baja pero el sortino lo vais a obtener fácilmente y es un
muy buen es un muy buen ratio es un muy buen rato también un ser index también y el performance
es que es el que usa él vale entonces a nivel de fitness podéis trabajar perfectamente con estos
luego la tercera elemento que es importante el tema de por folio es lo que lo que decía aquí
de caos man si es rebalancear o no rebalancear estoy buscando artículos no lo encuentro
un momentito no no ahora ese es el que ya viento si si si no en el otro en el otro creo que hablaba
también de esto de decía de sobre el ecuador el de los 50 años aquí hablaba del del ecuador
me perdí yo solo pero yo solo no sé dónde iba no sé dónde iba aquí el calendario todo esto
vale vale el tema el tema de si si rebalancear o no a ver lo normal es rebalancear eso es evidente
porque ahora por el mismo motivo que hablamos que los activos no es lo mismo unas a cada 5000
pues pues lo mismo no de acuerdo al final los por folios son dinámicos se mueve y hay que
igual que revisan los sistemas pues revisas el por folio es rebalancear y con cada cuando
se rebalancea tampoco hay una respuesta única de acuerdo yo esto creo ya lo contesté un día creo
en el disc or nosotros solemos hacerlo una vez al año si no se hace antes porque se revisa el
por folio entonces ahora por ejemplo vamos a hacer una revisión completa del por folio que
llevará pues el tiempo que lleve y pues lógicamente se rebalancea entonces porque
al final si lo que haces no tienes que rebalancear es evidente pero aún así si no se da el caso yo
recomiendo hacerlo por calendario aquí también entrar en factores nuevamente como os digo muchas
veces en nuestro caso que no no tiene por qué ser el bolso de entrada pero ojalá lo sea de un
tiempo o incluso puede que de alguien ya lo sea algo de cero lo que sea no claro no es lo mismo
bajar tu cuenta que trabajar cuentas gestionadas o para otras personas que están muchos factores
distintos y a veces pues tienes que hacer una mezcla ante lo que quieres y lo que puedes no como
es nuestro porfolio entonces aquí puede pasar por ejemplo por terminas de regulador que yo
esté obligado a tener un nivel de bar en este caso no lo llevan ellos pero si yo no lo llevan
a ellos yo estaría obligado nosotros en el fondo que teníamos con que sonaba yo de esfera que la
verdad que iba bastante bien tuvimos problemas de lanzamiento porque muchos eran problemas técnicos
pero la verdad que llevamos ya un año muy bueno cuando paramos y fuera lastima pero bueno si fue
el mercado es quebró y se lo quedó ambas y ambas no quiso seguir el proyecto y hubo que cerrarlo
pero pero la verdad que estaba ya muy bien con mucha una vez que ha sido muy buena teníamos
operamos yo que sé bu un sp nasta petróleo oro y teníamos ya preparados más cosas realmente
pero ahí sí que teníamos un objetivo de bar a cual tenemos un objetivo de bar que había que
controlar pues ahí pues tienes que controlarlo y pues hay que mediante tu excel y demás pues
vas viendo cuál es tu objetivo de bar y cuando te desvías una tolerancia pues no tienes que
ajustar puedes tener criterios pues bien bien por el regulador porque te los impone bien porque
tu cliente te los impone bien porque lo que sea no van a haber distintos criterios exigidos
por un condicionante no un condicionante entonces si no también en este caso que
los has obligado a controlar la volatilidad cada vez tiempo cada mes cada vez sino calendario
suele ir bien entendés decir lo que decimos siempre tiene un equilibrio entre práctica
recursos tiempo que dedico los recursos no son infinitos y por lo tanto hay que hay que
dedicarlos a las cosas que son más productivas normalmente tener un una una revisión del
porfolio por calendarios va a dar un resultado que quieres hacerlo cada trimestre que quieres
hacerlo cada mes normalmente va a ser demasiado que tengan estrategias muy sensibles muy intradía
pues todas igual pues sí pero normalmente no te va a hacer falta cada mes revisar el
porfolio aunque se haya desviado un poco que al final tienes que tener una tolerancia imagínate
que tú decidieras mantener un nivel de volatilidad en el porfolio máximo de un 10% que nunca la
volatilidad la desviación estándar vale simplemente el porfolio supera el 10% te pongas ese criterio
donde revisarías menos 12 por ciento menos 12 por ciento vamos al 10,1 revisar tienes mejor su
momento al 12 lo que vuelve a bajar tienes unas tolerancias de acuerdo unas tolerancias entonces
ahí hay distintos valores que tú puedes elegir lo que te decía por ejemplo también en la gestión
tú vas por pronominal pues sabes que no te puedes pasar el 100 por ciento es sagrado y no puedes
pasar ni un día entonces cada día tienes que medir que no te pases el 100% de exposición
entonces es depende pero por condiciones normales un ratio de calendario un criterio calendario es
ver bien y no hace falta ni tan sólo estar tan pendiente por vosotros decir porque no si está
bien diversificado y bien dimensionado a normal como habéis visto ahí en el gráfico que él solo
ya se auto ajuste no hayan desviaciones el mismo el de volatilidad si tienes un método de ejes
monetaria que controla volatilidad el mismo ya se auto ajusta tienes esta comodidad que
prácticamente no se te va a desviar lo puedes revisar a nivel de calendario pero casi es más
por la revisión de los sistemas que por el propio portfolio porque los pesos si el propio
money management ya se auto ajusta como habéis visto en el maestro no queda muy estable arriba
la exposición pues ya está ya ya lo hace de manera automática no hace falta mucho mucho más
pero si no ya os digo yo recomiendo que verdad una vez a la vez os volváis locos porque no
vais a ganar un poco por estar ahí porque encima hay muchas dudas sobre el rendimiento exacto el
porfolio mejor o sea es muy claro en el backtrash cuál va a ser mejor pero de elegir un peso u otro
hay mucha confusión la frontera eficiente muchos autores entre ellos yo mismo dicen que no acaba
de funcionar que es el método clásico de método a varianza aquellos que hay en la estudiatoria de
carteras es la frontera eficiente que es una frontera eficiente es decir elegir aquel porfolio
que da un mejor rentabilidad para misma unidad de riesgo es el concepto lógico que suena
de puta madre que es súper académico la universidad te verán esto no te le dices que lo haga él te lo
hará muy bien en un papel el problema es que luego lo mirarás un año después y no habrá pasado lo
que preveía es que pasaría ese es el problema entonces al final es muy difícil que cuando
participan varios elementos de la cartera o sea ya no sobre timitar un sistema por sí mismo pero
en este caso cuando tú metes varias estrategias entre sí ver que los retornos se distribuyen de
la misma manera que es lo que estás previendo no es nada fácil es nada fácil y por lo tanto
es complicado elegir mix por eso al final lo mejor es elegir estrategias como os digo sean buenas
robustas no meter por meter mejor meter tres buenos que seis regulares me entiendes y equal
por volatilidad ajustar volatilidades que no se os vaya la volatilidad de madre y ya está y si
el propio mone management ya controla la volatilidad ya el porfolio va a estar ajustado bien una señal
de aviso por alguna desviación y si no una vez al año revisamos revisamos que se todo igual que
lo normal es que sí vale y hasta no hace falta tal que luego lo vas a optimizar vas a tener un
programa de porfolio sin lo va a utilizar te va a decir si mira mejor este un peso de 07 y
este 02 y este 04 y hubieran ganado un 30% más vale muy bien bueno probarlo si al final
tienes no tiene no tiene no tiene tampoco ningún ningún problema hacerlo pero lo normal es que es
que sea similar siempre primar diversificación en cualquiera lo que sí que os digo en caso de que
entre ese proceso de optimización de porfolios que hay programas que lo hacen sobre todo sobre
todo sobre todo mi consejo es que diseñéis todo siempre limitando mínimos y máximos es decir no
permitáis que por por el algoritmo la función fitness que sea que le pongáis ponga 0 a 1 y
mucho otro tiene que pasar por delante y la diversificación pasa porque todo opere todo
pero el único criterio para no operar es porque algún sistema que nosotros no lo hacemos ya
diseñamos pensando que pueda operar siempre pero hay autores que lo hacen es decir que puedan
pararlo un sistema es decir por exceso de volatilidad lo para si está estudiado así es
correcto no es malo si tú ya lo estudias el sistema si yo cuando la volatilidad es
tanto se me separa se ha analizado se ha diseñado así perfecto en un problema nosotros preferimos
que opere siempre aunque a lo mejor en ese momento pues opere el mínimo posible un lote en el caso
de si para otro tamaño de tu cuenta es el un lote es demasiado pues a lo mejor es mejor pararlo
vamos un momento con un porfolio para un momentito que me comentaba una cosa mientras
abro el programa y todo esto bueno mira si queréis queréis mira hacer una pausa porque
lo tengo que abrir y bueno puede rápido puede no porque como he tenido que cerrar antes 3 eso
por lo que habéis visto que me ha reventado entonces lo tenía abierto pero lo tengo que abrir así que
si queréis paramos 2 minutos 2 minutos o 3 y volvemos vale estamos de nuevo es esta breve
pausa para seguir con la clase bueno aprovechado para abrir esto tenemos algunos porfolios de
ejemplo tenemos un algo que francamente entra casi en el terreno de lo paranormal ahora encima
me pierde 10.000 sólo alberto vamos mejorando vamos mejorando porque pero bueno que viene muy
bien a efectos de lo que queremos enseñaros porque aquí ha bajado la exposición ahora
ahora tengo la exposición un poco recortada
multicharts tiene cosas muy buenas a nivel de porfolio es mucho más eficiente permite
además enseñar un porfolio luego operarlo está muy bien de acuerdo permite hacer back test
incluso optimizar hacer forward testing también en teoría maestro pero la práctica no por lento
y como os digo permite automatizar la operativa ya optimizar y luego ponerlo
automatizar directamente la ejecución que es configurar lo demás pero lo puedes configurar
para operar por lo demás a mí esto parece bastante rudimental y bastante pobre hay una
página de ayuda y los que lo uséis que explica un poco todo esto lo explica regular pero bueno
ahí está y también lo que os decía antes para aquellos que tengáis más poco más de
desperté de conocimiento programación y demás pues saber que también hay palabras reservadas
de porfolio lo que os decía también para lo para las propiedades para las propiedades margen
cintas opciones y también para el estado de simposición de acuerdo pues y como no pues
el open position profit de porfolio el net profit del porfolio que es quizá lo más lo más
interesante lo más interesante para aquellos que lo quieran esto está está está explicado ya que
lo quiera usar pues que lo sepa nosotros en este porfolio no lo hemos usado va todo con las
definiciones generales del programa que están aquí esto no sé por qué porque a mí todo lo
pero paso y ya está que no tenéis un poco poco explicado simplemente simplemente un par de
declaraciones aquí tienes un criterio porque aquí he puesto ahora 10 por ciento aquí ahora puesto
10 por ciento 20 si tú si tú le aquí tú le puedes fijar unos límites de cuánto capital del
porfolio cuánto le dedicas a cada posición pero eso al final actúa de límite no quiere decir que
uses eso al final tú el money management lo vienes fijado por el sistema también lo puedes cargar
aquí como una señal nosotros lo tenemos ya puesto en el sistema por lo tanto es el que cuenta esto
actúa de límite entiendes decir si si el money management del sistema pasara ese límite no
entraría pero lo normal es que ya tuvo con el que tienes implementado en el sistema ya lo
tengas calculado a cada cada uno una parte y está entiendes es un poco la idea aquí hemos
puesto algunos de los temas que hemos visto sin más no nos hemos vuelto muy locos hay
bolinguer bans en este caso en el mismo version de bolinguer bans que eran si se más la mayoría
no todos son muy justos hay un RCI short y un RCI long que esto es del RCI de breakout con salidas
pero bueno viene viene de la es parecido a las salidas en las salidas hay un RCI
el tendencial que hicimos intradía el ORB intradía que eran todos bastante justitos el tumorro
que no quise un poco mejor es decir hay unos cuantos de los que hemos de los que hemos visto
acuerdo y está hecho expresamente de acuerdo está hecho expresamente para que veáis que
incluso con una mezcla de sistemas bastante pobres se puede conseguir una curva estable esto como ya
os comenté cuando los íbamos haciendo os dije que lo veríais que es así por lo veríais que es
así porque es que es así si realmente son sistemas distintos que es que relacionan activos
prácticamente es imposible que no lo sea es imposible que no que no lo sea aquí además
pasa una curiosidad porque alberto del dax le gana y no hemos conseguido entender por qué aquí
pierde incluso tenemos un sistema que pierde dinero también como habéis habéis visto antes
del dax alberto le gana no no hemos conseguido está guardado igual no entiendo es un fenómeno
como os digo que está alcanzando casi lo paranormal porque no entendemos esto de igual mismo
proveedor de datos no los hemos bajado el caché de datos no se ve el problema con los datos no
sé si nos está escapando algo es evidente pero es que está guardado en su ordenador y yo abierto
aquí pero bueno aquí lo que os decía antes de los programas todos tienen sus buenas y malas
porfolio traders en global es mucho mejor que maestro simplemente por por su eficiencia pero
es y porque puede operar pero es verdad que a eso tiene gráficos muy chulos pero ya digo este
es tema de poder operar es muy potente aquí fijaros que obtenemos ratios por cada te los da
también por cada sistema eso está está realmente bien y te da también lo que decíamos antes
vale esta está la hasta pasaban en horario que no hace falta que además es un tanto absurdo
le acabo de dar y le acabo el hierbo que me va a tardar un montón en fin pero ahí está no es que
no tiene sentido no tiene sentido no tiene sentido que tenéis ver las correlaciones en base a todos
fijaros que sólo el nasdaq con el sp en este caso lo hace por símbolos ahí por ejemplo en
multicharts te deja verlo por strategy group que está muy bien que al final puedes hacerlo por
estrategia aquí te lo dice por activos porque al final es verdad que tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 que en
realidad son sistemas que fijaros que el NASA que se ha repetido porque el sistema el sistema
realidad el porfolio donde lo tengo es aquí debajo es 1 2 el primero es en el sp 60 segundo
dax diario oro 60 en nasdaq diario nasdaq diario esos son los dos nasdaq se está ordenando esto
es tu morro esto es o reventar día esto es tendencia al oro entraría esto es rsi long esto
es rsi short que son los dos en el nasdaq fijaros que fijaros que el nasdaq rsi long tiene 0 5 con
tu morro que los dos van largos eso que os decía siendo activos con mucha correlación pero
los dos tendenciales tienen 0 5 que es bastante que es bastante pero oye siendo los dos largos y
los dos de activos con mucha correlación tampoco está mal del todo pero fijaros del resto donde
todos están en cero prácticamente es decir estamos explicando muy bien porque son muy distintos
muy distintos porque tenemos un sp diario con las dos danas de diario pero luego tenemos un
sp en 60 que va más bien en tendencia porque tu morro es más bien casi tendencia en cambio el
otro cp es muy reverso con lo cuanto es que tenemos los dos sps sd con tenemos 0 0 0 0
siendo el mismo activo se lo hemos montado un poco para que veáis este tipo de cosas cada
uno lo hemos montado pensando en que veáis una cosa es aquí veis el mismo activo y tienen 0 0 6
porque tienen sistemas muy distintos y te hay frame distinto incluso el dax fijaros con el con
nasdaq y con sp casi tiene cero con todos y oro pues prácticamente con todos con todos cero
prácticamente con todos tiene cero y da y da casi también siendo bolsa también porque porque el
dax estamos hablando de uno rb 10 minutos no tiene que ver con por mucho que sea sp y nasdaq activos
que tienen mucha correlación entre sí tienen cero porque porque la mejor diversificación es
por sistema cada si el sistema es parecido como pasa en nasdaq sp pues a 0 5 que aún así es no
no es mala y no pasa nada que haya uno sí pero lógicamente pues mejor que no está realmente bien
aquí podéis ver un poco la diversificación esto está también con nuestro ratio de ejes
humanitarios y al final aquí por ejemplo está falta ese gráfico gráfico de exposición en
la exposición me acuerdo se veis aquí en el tectenálisis pues ves que va a 1 2 lotes 3 va
moviéndose por eso porque va variando por base a la bola al final es veríais lo mismo que el
maestro porque es el mismo va capando pasa que aquí como hay menos capital realmente al final
cuando va creciendo acaba operando uno porque el valor del nominal se hace muy alto es de todas
maneras seguramente lo puedo mitigar bueno le puedo añadir si no no pero sigue sigue en el
nivel es y le pongo aquí que vaya al límite que uso del algoritmo puedo poner un 0 más lo que pasa
que he quedado como en el sistema está capado no va a ir no va a hacer nada no va a hacer nada
porque manda el sistema y el sistema tiene un multiplicador si yo en el sistema para eso viene
bien lo que lo que os decía vale que no lo hemos hecho aquí y os lo he avisado pero siguió aquí
en vez de usar el equity del sistema como hacemos también el maestro vale yo hubiera usado
en cada sistema entendéis en vez de usar el net profit hubiera usado donde estás ahora
hubiera usado por folio net profit entendéis hubiera usado por folio net profit entonces sí
que ahora al mover el capital esto movería ves no se ha movido que da igual porque aunque yo le
aumento el por folio y le aumentó estos límites yo tengo un cálculo en el sistema que se acordáis
porque lo veáis en cualquiera al final a no ser este es que no tenemos las manos abierto
con el sonido de gémito
este aquí al final pues acaba usando lo que ya sabéis es que me sea con ese ajuste normalizada
tal tal tal pero al final que tiene un net profit y no puede ser un profit que depende del valor
que tiene el propio sistema de acuerdo por lo tanto tiene un capital y asignado entendéis que
pero realmente si yo no si yo ahí en vez de usar net profit hubiera usado el profit del
porfolio yo ahora al mover este importe hubiera movido todos los sistemas entendéis ahí entonces
por eso puede venir bien puede venir bien adentrarse un poco en esto que no es muy
complicado tampoco son cuatro o cinco palabras simplemente es eso yo le pongo aquí por folio
el profit y punto y esto en principio cambia esto es que lo podemos probar rápido porque creo
que no va a dar ningún problema sí sí sí lo podemos cambiar cuando encuentre quedan a lo
cerrado lo cerrado por aquí un guión no me deje antes para acabar ahora voy a explicaros un
detallito ya ya lo dejaremos que ya ya son las las nueve pero donde tengo yo lo de maestro lo
cerrado no lo cerrado si si si lo cerrado lo busco aquí en el historial que va a ser más más rápido
por folio el profit y open position el profit también no en estas sitios profit que la copio
no bueno se lo tenía que poner a todos para hacerlo bien pero para para ahora para ahora
probarlo vale no no no me no me supone mucho simplemente lo he cambiado en uno y ahora veremos
el porfolio cambiado si he compilado que venía a cambiar porque le he cambiado aquí el que ha
cambiado no no le he cambiado pero vamos a hacer uno lo vamos a cambiar de música simplemente
se cambia el importe ya está si más se ha cambiado un poco das cuenta de la 802 pero
está un poco buggy pero pero le he metido 10 pero sigue teniendo sus límites o sea y es un
sistema solo te lo voy a meter dos cerros más ahora para ver a ver si realmente actúa o no
que 100 por fin que actúa porque tengo aquí déjamelo mirar por favor o sea claro piensa que
sólo a profit si si si lo cambiaron a mirarnos esto estaría a punto de reventar está a punto
de reventar cuanto era antes bueno también pensaba que puede actual el límite cuando era antes
el 859 entonces a ver por qué deja ver no porque sólo he cambiado el net profit claro no no no
porque está mal está mal no me he equivocado o sea no he cambiado estar equity tampoco no he
cambiado a ser teco y no he cambiado a ser teco y entonces es una pequeña parte sólo por folio
es sólo lo has visto que no me acuerdo no estoy buscando
que tú has observado te quedan de agua los cash assets investe de porfolio
seguridad de móvel o que están descalculando invested capital a los
nosotros sólo veo el de ahora o el complete straight por la porfolio vale lo
eso es invested capital es el maestro creo que se llama después pero no encuentros
invested capital net profit y no lo encuentro es increíble pero no lo encuentro bueno yo lo
voy a dejar porque no lo encuentro es igual no controlo el profit y encuentro open position profit
no lo encuentro pero da igual es igual es igual si es la es la es la idea al final tiene que haber
una manera de referirse a este capital seguro porque si no tiene sentido que sólo te puedas
referir al net profit no tiene pero no lo encuentro ahora no lo encuentro la verdad vale bien la
otra cosa quería en todo caso insisto igual al final quería enseñaros era era esto de acuerdo
la mezcla de distintas estrategias hemos dicho cómo partir del capital inicial y que vierais aquí
simplemente pues que consigues curvas puedes conseguir curvas estables simplemente diversificando
por estrategias bastante cómodas aquí el sistema para quien lo ha visto gana poco pero aquí está
mal dimensionado ahora claro como le he puesto tantos ceros está tremendamente infra expuesto
entonces al final está tremendamente infra expuesto por eso ganaba tampoco pero porque
el sistema sigue usando el money management en todos ellos en uno está usando el net profit
porque no le da para el profit varía poco en relación a el cálculo que hace usa el
start equity el start equity sigue siendo el suyo entonces no varía no varía mucho vale ahora aquí
esta vez tiene un 5 por ciento pero tiene un 845 de retort sobre el máximo de lo que está bastante
bien al final el drawdown máximo que tiene y caros que es un 8 aquí en el inicio está mal
dimensionado en realidad porque tiene el problema del apalancamiento asimétrico por eso deberíamos
haberle puesto mucho más capital por eso cuando los vamos a hacer eso porque ese es el problema
cuando lo hagáis a menos lo recomiendo hacer aunque penséis que no es realista si queréis
ver un poco cómo se mueve realmente el comportamiento de cada estrategia dimensionara más de lo que
operaréis luego ya lo probaréis también con el que operaréis pero esto esto que veis aquí todo
el rato operando un contrato genera muchos problemas porque al final cuando salta de 1 a 2 dobla el
riesgo si este tren lo falla está expuesto el doble que el anterior entonces ese problema
del apalancamiento que llamamos asimétrico que luego subir y bajar no es igual entonces cuando
hay muy pocos contratos un poco cuenta tienes ese problema en futuros así que sí que es verdad que
es mejor si puedes problema pero es que no hay más remedio así que es verdad que es útil que al
menos empiece como mínimo con 2 porque ya de 2 a 3 el salto es menor que de 1 a 2 entonces al menos
pero es que no puede ser hoy es no puede ser pues no puede ser bueno hablamos de lo ideal y como
lo que puedes y lo que quieres y todo eso no pero por eso os digo que aquí no se aprecia es el
el dragón abajo porque el capital ha ido subiendo las cuentas el sp todo ha ido subiendo acordaros
que también se tiene en cuenta el nominal y por lo tanto no se puede exponer más no le da tiempo
a saltar a más contratos por eso parece que esté muy poco expuesto que tenga menos nada si eso
estuviera igual todo en 10 12 15 contratos seguramente del lado abajo sería más estable se entiende
verdad ya para acabar también quiero no quería dejar de mencionar porque aunque no me lo habéis
preguntado también es un tema que a veces sale y que es interesante que hay autores que hablan de
ello que es el tema de reducir o no en base al dragón reducir la exposición es decir tú tú
evidentemente nosotros fijaros aquí que hemos hablado antes de reducir la exposición no cuando
hay volatilidad vale porque hago es estimado de los y yo también tengo una mala racha en el
sistema puede parecer que sea lógico también reducir la exposición cuando tengo pérdidas
independientemente de la volatilidad es decir o sea incorporar ese cálculo incorporar ese cálculo
y no había sistemas no había por folios decir imaginaros que yo aquí en este gráfico es para
que le voy a quitar le voy a quitar un cero para que me me haga mucho drawdown entonces
imaginaos que yo tengo un drawdown muy elevado yo tengo un criterio que a la que me acerco porque
sé aquí tengo yo por ejemplo un gráfico este este es el drawdown es el dragón de desío recuerdo
real de operativas reales estos del dragón de operativas real que ahora hemos estado cerca del
10 entonces fijaros que aquí desde el punto de vista conceptual yo veo por un lado que tengo
aquí un dragón siempre de esta zona si lo puedo hacer un poco más grande esto se ve bien no en
todo caso se ve bien no ahora ahora la regla la regla la regla la regla la regla entonces
esto imaginaos que yo tengo que fijaros aquí en la zona 10 12 no parece que es la zona de
lado máximo a veces era un poco más poco menos podría ser un poco más pero se ve no hay varias
zonas y es verdad que se aprecia que luego tiene otra zona no puede estar aquí es que también
está aquí cuando llega pues se visita y ahí tiene tiene cierta vez no es ahí era y otro la zona
pues más intermedio no más intermedio que sobre todo que cuando se sale de ahí de acuerdo cuando
se sale de ahí me voy a poner otro color lo voy a hacer con esto vale cuando se sale de ahí veis
aquí pues se puede pensar que la mayoría de veces acaba yendo a la zona de abajo no siempre
pero tienden a la idea y entonces hay autores que defienden nosotros esto hoy en día no lo hacemos
pero tiene sentido hacerlo te explico como os he dicho de todo el curso explico cosas que
hacemos cosas pues que no hacemos pero que a lo mejor podríamos hacerlas un día o no entiendes
decir no no las cosas pueden cambiar no reducir la exposición simplemente porque el porfolio
el draud por por por por tener una variable que controla el draudón del porfolio vale y ahí por
decir pues un 30% la exposición o un 20 o lo que lo que sea vale esto tiene sentido recuerdo
hay autores que lo hacen a mí me genera dudas me genera dudas pero como os digo lo explico me
genera dudas porque el problema siempre que hago este tipo de ajustes es cuando vuelvo y como no
cuando vuelvo y como entonces si al final tú vas por volatilidad demás y crees que el sistema está
bien pues ya todo debe devolver a la normalidad de acuerdo por sí solo pero sí que es verdad que
esto te puede prevenir mirar aquí estabas cargado el drama y tenemos mucho más fuertes pues a lo
mejor te puede prevenir de la duda es un poco más catastróficos que queda un poco sea medio roto
porque porque seguramente ha entrado se ha sobre expuesto aquí demás pero sí que a lo mejor pues
puede tener sentido puede tener sentido que sea partir en este gráfico de locos pues yo que sé
si es 65 el máximo pues en 40 no en 40 reduzco tendréis un poco la idea o es igual aquí en 50
en 30 mil 30 mil 30 mil se ve justamente perfecto en color el color que he elegido se ve se ve de
maravilla para que se entienda un poco la idea no a lo mejor tiene sentido puede tener sentido el
tema es que tienes que fijar si haces esto esto sería por por folio de acuerdo y tendrás que
reducir todos los sistemas y automáticamente fijar una reanudación que debería de tener un margen de
tolerancia nuevamente de acuerdo esto puede tener sentido hacerlo yo lo explico porque es algo que
hay autores que hacen y que nosotros como digo ahora no lo hacemos pero podríamos hacerlo
no es nada no es nada que sea una tontería y es verdad que tiene que es criterio de
prudencia al final es criterio de prudencia bueno nada más lo vamos a dejar aquí
no hay más tú no se sabía porque me ha parecido ir algo en el disco no
pues lo vamos a dejar aquí hasta el día
que sea os llegar el aviso como siempre igual ahora activar es un caso el aviso de también
una semana vale pero como queda lejos antes no lo había hecho pero pondría aviso una semana antes
un día antes de una hora antes para que nadie se le olvide de acuerdo trataré sería empezar muy
puntual incluso brilantes y para tratar de como digo si que dejar cualquier duda
respondida vale tenéis el disco tenéis el email ponerlas en el disco se puede ser que si todo el
mundo puede aportarla trataremos de llevarlas todas bien preparadas y he tomado nota de todas
las cosas como el cot el bix referencias de activos y activos todo vale un poco para tener
ese material listo para poderlo dar también en la clase en esta última clase que
podemos prácticamente yo creo que con esto la mayoría de las cosas que hemos dicho que
daríamos estarán nada puede que de algo puede que de algo yo creo que quedaría la mayoría estaría
dado también sobre todo por favor si me falta yo mañana voy a tratar de recopilarlo todo pero
si algo alguien ya sabe oye dijiste que subirías esto y no lo has subido me refiero de las prácticas
ponerlo en el disco por favor porque me ayudáis mucho de acuerdo mayores mucho y dijiste que no
sé qué en las prácticas digo yo no digo de la teoría digo lo que sea la clase 3 quedó pendiente
no sé qué la casa cuando yo mañana voy a tratar de revisarlo todo para que no quede nada que
pendiente de subiros códigos vale pseudo código de todo lo que hemos dado en la práctica para
que lo todo lo podáis lo podáis tener y por mi parte nada más nos vemos el próximo
lo quiero de lo quiero decir bien lo quiero decir bien porque queda grabado
día 11 verdad además lo tengo aquí lo tengo aquí día 11 que lo voy a mirar en la plataforma
para no tener duda alguna día 11 a las 6 de acuerdo día 11 a las 6 es la día 11 de junio
de acuerdo día 11 de junio y a 11 de junio en un mes en un mes tenemos esta última clase de repaso
dudas finales que tengáis de teoría y de práctica y fin de fin de clase ya nos vamos todos de juerga
juntos los que vengáis a rehus pues ya los vamos todos a quemar rehus directamente y
a más nos escribe que falta el control de supervisión de alberto alberto quedó pendiente
es verdad alberto ha dicho joder es verdad lo tiene hecho si si no no mañana no más a ver si
mañana nos subimos todo en este mes lo subiremos mañana lo vamos a revisar todo lo que falta este
ya está apuntado gracias y ya lo apuntaremos todos a ser posible lo subiremos en breve pero
si no pues a lo largo de las próximas semanas antes de la práctica lo dejamos lo dejamos todo
todo listo vale nada más no me preguntas pongo carátula que siempre queda mejor para acabar
el vídeo y me despido a todos vosotros hasta el próximo 11 que es así que será la última espero
y poder hacerlo de acuerdo hasta pronto amigos chau